toward the end of your book what you
don't learn in film school shane you
have this story it's a fascinating story
where you said you saved a hollywood
studio
what 50 million it was about
yeah and it was it was for a very large
trilogy
that they were producing at the time and
what had happened is they they had
committed to making three blockbuster
movies you know tent polls over the
course of i think five or six years
and they had tremendous success with the
first one it was it was
everything that they make these kind of
movies for and more and
the second one had come out and not done
very well
and i got a phone call one day from
somebody that i had worked with when i
was doing studio work and
i guess he had talked to one of the
heads of production at this other studio
and said you know you need to kind of
flip the script on your mindset
you really need to get an indie rat to
look at your budget your schedule and
your script and let somebody go in with
the mindset that understands production
at this level but thinks
thinks you know how do you make
something for a dollar really for a dime
and i got a phone call out of the blue
one day and it was the head of
production for a studio and they they
had me come in they wouldn't talk much
about it on the phone it was very
hush-hush and covert everything was in
code and i walked into the boardroom and
there was all these people sitting
around a horseshoe table with you know
their fiji bottles of water and their
highlighter pens or sharpies and their
pads of paper and they had a seat for me
and i couldn't figure out why i was
there and you know one of the the
head-head people came in he was wearing
a suit i remember that
and
told me the situation and what they were
dealing with and how they had made
really big commitments
going into the third that the second
film's lack of success did not justify
they but they were contractually
obligated to certain escalations in
people's pay
they were shooting in different
countries all over the world
um so they asked if i would um
take a look at the they wanted me to
look at the first two films
then they wanted me to break down the
third one just from my perspective and
it was
it was heavy cgi you know it was a big
tentpole studio movie it's not what i do
um but they had me go through everything
and
we
spent a few days i had to do everything
there i wasn't allowed to leave with any
materials my cell phone had to be far
there was a person in the room with me
at all times
and just broke it down and it's just
common sense common sense common sense
and then you know i'd see a way to save
you know
a lot of money
and they would tell me no you can't do
that because we have this contract in
place or there are these agreements with
unions or
you know we have to pay these actors
these scales but
it was interesting looking at a budget
for a film that was you know over 200
million dollars
i mean you know when you're making films
that are
comfortably you know in that million
dollar range
and you know you you find a place for
every dime and you make sure it
stretches and you start looking at where
money is going at
dollars
at that level it's mind-blowing you know
the money that's spent wasted that'll
never see the screen you know perk
packages daily per diems and bonuses and
private jets back and forth
hotels that cost a fortune that these
these actors will be in to just sleep a
couple hours you know a few hours a
night
um it's mind-blowing and um
so i i felt very fortunate to be a part
of that process it it reminded me
of
the difference between being an
independent filmmaker and and really
being in embedded with the studio system
and this was at a time when when the
studios were just spending so much money
and there i don't think there was a real
checks and balances on where these these
dollars were going it was it's about
give the actors what they need
give the filmmakers what they need you
know above the line producers i think
there were
17 of them 18 of them that's not
including the talent
um you know cinematographers and
high-end
crew i mean there were some really big
crew people on this too and this was a
big film
and i i think
you know looking back
that
i don't think anything's changed with
them you know
it's no surprise that a studio will
gladly spend 200 million dollars to make
20 million i mean that's obviously not
the goal but
that's kind of the business model for a
lot of the studios you know a lot of
people say well 80 of studio films fail
that's true
but
what we deem a failure just because we
look at the domestic box office doesn't
mean globally it was a failure it's a
lot of ways that they can still make
money on ancillaries and different
outlets for their project or you know
plushies and toys and all the stuff that
come with it
but um it was an interesting experience
and it
it really
made me appreciate what
we do as independent filmmakers and and
why i really i think it was an
experience like that because i just come
off of making gridiron gang shortly
before
and was lining up to do some more studio
and network projects
and i remember walking away from that
and just saying you know sure who
wouldn't want a paycheck like some of
these people were getting of course we
who wouldn't
but when it comes down to getting movies
made and loving what you do and who you
do it with
and passion for maybe it's your art
passion for working with the people you
care about or just want to kick a movie
out every year or two
it really it really kind of helped push
me into the direction of just saying you
know what that that isn't
what i want to pursue i want to be able
to find people that want to go
get their hands dirty
stretch a buck
shoot where we're not supposed to shoot
shoot with cameras that aren't the
newest or the coolest
and go make fun movies that you know
people may or may not like
it was kind of a life-changing
experience for me
i'm glad we saved the studio a lot of
money i mean it was i couldn't remember
it was 38 or 52. i haven't read that
part of the book in a while
but
there was we saved them a lot of money i
mean
and just common sense money
where was most of the money being spent
that you ended up cutting
um most of the money was um believe it
or not
um
studios spend an outrageous amount of
money in post-production on films like
that
and
they have contracts they have ways that
they're going to put money into
something from one account into another
you know that that happens when you know
they'll have three edit bays working on
one film that's a walk and talk drama
you know they can have an apprentice
editor setting things up for the
assistant editor the assistant editor
setting up things for the other editor
and the amount of money they're charging
for these
these kit fees and these bungalow
rentals and you know there are there are
union jobs so those pay scales are what
they are unless you're getting an
academy award winner a real hot editor
but what i notice is just
i i know a lot of veterans i mean
editing's my back my background uh cgi
i've got a lot of people in my life that
do that and when you start budgeting
things and you start getting teams of 30
40 50 people to do something that you
see you know you can cut this down you
don't have to go this route you could go
to a different country you don't have a
contract with this country to do post
you can talk to these guys here they
would love your business and probably
cut this most of these things were done
in post and cgi and and just kind of
reworking perks i mean it was even
you know studios have their private jets
they they perk out you know and have
deals with hotels all over the world but
there's only so many jets to go around
so
it was it even got to the point where we
were literally making deals with other
private charter services and other
people that we knew in the private
airline business that were able to help
save a lot of money because you know a
flight from la to new york people don't
realize a private plane flight could
cost over 20 grand
it's not a cheap flight so imagine
flying people from la to other parts of
the world
and
trying to just connect dots with
transportation coordinators that weren't
going to
bruise any egos but just kind of inform
some of the executives on where they
could go
and
that's what we did now how much money
they ended up
using
on that savings or you know how much
whatever the dollar amount was that we
saved
i don't know what they ended up spending
i just know on paper
following all their guidelines and rules
and their you know what they asked you
know us to adhere to in
putting together a new budget it was it
was pretty substantial you know for all
i know they spent more than that
uh than the original budget they
probably did but
you know it checked everything checked
out it was doable
and during this meeting were there
certain topics that made them
uncomfortable when you said let's cut
this and we'll do this and we'll move
this over here and you could see ooh
that's that's probably not going to work
for them um there's a lot of looking
around you know what i found in in in a
system like that is
it
there's a pecking order there is a
hierarchy and and as there isn't most
business and a lot of people um when
you'd suggest something you wouldn't get
one person saying yes or no you get a
lot of people looking to one or two
different people and then looking to
another person and then it just ends up
going to the head of the table anyway
you know um
so
it's it's rare people are going to go
out on a limb and say that's that's what
we need to do it kind of you know the
ideas always played pinball or would
come back after three or four
discussions to a no or hey that's good
can we try this over there and they were
very
forward thinking once they started
seeing it wasn't like i reinvented the
wheel for them it was just getting them
to just kind of throttle back a little
bit on the hemorrhaging of money on
everything giving everybody everything
okay you have made these commitments to
these actors
i get that but they don't need to know
what you're spending on these things
these gift perks these you know hotel
rooms or
these other perks that go on that these
actors are giving up films at that level
there's different ways to
to still give them what you're
contractually obligated to give them and
save and we were getting to the point we
were literally saving
two three hundred dollars on every gift
basket
i mean that's that's the kind of stuff
we were literally getting down to we
were doing everything we could to save
them money
gift basket so that is a typical thing
on certain sets oh sure sure the studios
treat their actors really well and i i
think even independent filmmakers you
know should if they don't when you get
an actor that shows up on your film
that's you know a special get i think i
think welcoming them with something even
if it's a fruit basket or a bottle of
nail polish or something is good
but studios you know
they they have some
really
you know and there's a lot of
sponsorship that comes with that too
it's kind of like the oscars but there
is costs there are you know all sorts of
things that go into these things
that cost money everything costs money
and you know when you start going in
with the mindset of okay instead of just
saying you're gonna spend five thousand
dollars on every gift basket and it's
gonna end up costing you 2500 to 3500
after you get the free how do you
make them feel equally special for five
or six hundred dollars and it's it's
doable it's just about taking the time
to break it down and not just throwing
the money at the problem
sure and then you said the hotel room
where they may just stay over well yeah
unfortunately there wasn't a lot we
could do with hotel rooms because of
contracts you know various studios and
production entities you know especially
when studios are going to other parts of
the world
there are a lot of setups already so
they're not going to you're not going to
go in and ruffle too many feathers with
that but it's just the cost and it's
reminding them that
you may not think 5 000 for a gift
basket is a lot of money for an actor
but you're also spending this much at
night on a hotel room and in reality
they're going to spend 12 12 hours a day
on a set
then they're going to be doing this this
this press junket maybe this
and
at the end of the day this is with the
exception of their days off this is
where they're going to hang their head
at night
and how how can some of these things be
worked out and i think most of those
things were kind of finagled more for
not the top tier level of actor but it
was about finding other similar
accommodations that were substantially
lower i mean it's it's not rocket
surgery i mean i've got i've got a
nephews getting married at pebble beach
coming up and they threw us all the
available hotels
and i mean i think the rooms start at
1200 1400 a night and you know
those two things i don't pay for myself
is a nice fancy hotel room and a
first-class airfare you know i'm just
sitting on a plane going from a to b
i'll do a coach i have no problem with
that
um
i made three phone calls and i i i'm
basically five minutes from the wedding
spending 209 a night for the wedding
that's just the mentality that i have
you know i just think there's money that
is better served somewhere else and and
so i that's the mentality i kind of took
with them and everything
and um you know they were receptable to
a lot of the ideas again did they end up
doing it i know i wasn't leaving until i
was able to show them a savings so they
at least
accepted what i presented at the end of
the day
but
i couldn't tell you what they ended up
spending you never know but i know that
they were they were concerned going in
and needed needed some cuts so i i don't
think they just brought me in to
have me warm a seat for three days
well i don't want to blow my street cred
here but what is an indie rat
i'm an indie rat it's people that just
you know
they don't wait for the machine they
figure out a way you know it's i i
always you know i talk about in the book
is you know give me an actor a camera
and a place to do it and let's go make a
movie it's it's
not waiting for a machine to decide you
know when all the stars align you know i
had when we did gridiron gang um we made
that deal i believe in 1993
it was the most sought after property in
hollywood everybody had bid on it but
paramount
and you know hundreds of producers
directors and actors all wanted to be a
part of it and then it gets to the
studio and it took two years to finally
go into turnaround it never got made
and you know
fast forward to 2006
you know
and
i just i know not every film goes
through that but
it's not uncommon
and i had spent some time at a network
after doing gridiron i was brought on
to to develop in-house projects for a
major network
with a writing partner of mine at the
time
and we spent i think 13 months there
talking about a lot of great projects
that never got made
and these were passion projects that the
network wanted to do these weren't our
ideas it was we were brought in to do
the passion projects that the high ups
wanted to see get made
and the meetings and the development
discussions and i'll never forget it you
know um
the the vp of the the network brought me
into his office one day after our 100th
you know development meeting on one show
and
it was friday and he said you like
scotch i said i like scotch he poured us
a scotch we put our feet up on his
coffee table and shot the breeze for a
few minutes and he said
you're a filmmaker man you don't belong
here he said i can see your frustration
he said i he's you'll always have an
open door with me
but i think you need to just go out and
make movies he goes this isn't how you
work
i said yeah i just don't understand it i
said we've been here 13 months we've
gone from this project for four months
to oh that's not cool anymore let's jump
on this one oh that's that's not gonna
fit in today's climate and then we go to
something else and i said here we're on
round three in 13 months and we haven't
done anything i said you know my idea is
write something that you're excited
about get some friends together and go
shoot it and that's that's what i do
that's what i believe in
and
i think at that point
i had just gotten to in my life was
where it was about just just doing what
we wanted to do and it doesn't agree
with everybody and not everybody likes
what i do and that's not why i don't do
it for people like it i do it because i
need to do it to just to feel alive
that's
you know what i need to do
and
it's it's been it's been a lot of fun
and and i wouldn't trade those days in
doing the studio film or you know
working with the networks the way i did
it it taught me so much to be able to do
what i do today
because i can see it from both sides i
can see it from a creative person who
doesn't have a lot of budget to work
with but i also know the end game and
when this thing is done where it has to
go how it how it has to be exploited
around the world
and and making sure we check the boxes
that you know all 54 territories and 172
countries that are out there that buy
there's something in it for everybody
how can
the quote unquote indie rats and the
quote unquote suits harmoniously work
together
because each needs each other each needs
each other that's a that is a great
question um
i wish i had all the answers and i i'd
like to think i play well with others i
i some of the greatest relationships
i've had in this town have been with the
suits
um
and i
p what people we all have to remember
this is a business at the end of the day
but it's like let's take something like
the car business which we talked about
before
you have the people that actually design
the cars that you know
have jobs designing and engineering then
you have the people that actually have
to be the executives behind the decision
to greenlight a car being made and then
you have the car dealerships that are
going to acquire the cars and then you
have the salesmen who have to sell them
and then you got the mechanics who have
to work on them everybody needs each
other it's kind of like on a film set we
have a rule where i don't care if you're
the star of the show if you're a pa
you're all equal to this machine running
in in harmony and we all need to show
respect for one another and i think
i think there's always been a little bit
of a clash between the suits and the the
filmmaker
um but i think if if people can get on
the same page
and i think i think if the
executives would trust the artist that
they're
giving their money to or distributing i
think if you fall in love with an idea
you fall in love with the script or a
filmmaker's vision from a previous film
you need to decide i either trust this
person
to run with it or i don't and i think
when you get too many cooks in the
kitchen
um
i think it stifles the creativity i i
know i've been involved with some pretty
pretty big projects where the suits and
the artists couldn't ever get along it
got very
very intense it got it got explosive at
times even on sets where a studio exec
will show up
not happy with the director for a style
they're shooting in or
unhappy because a dp is moving the
camera too much and
the the tempers that flare on set in
front of everybody i mean you know we
are in a industry of children
whether we like it or not um and i just
i just don't think it needs to be that
way and i think
communication is key it's not just okay
we believe in you you're getting paid go
shoot this movie and then we look at
dailies and we tell you what we like and
don't like and when you start doing that
to an artist it really the hair on the
back of their neck goes up i've seen it
time and time again
and i just think there's
i think there's probably some basic
fundamentals i find a lot of suits spend
a lot of time psychoanalyzing things
they take a lot of classes and body
language how to read somebody's
temperament across the desk or across
the room
and i don't think they've been taught
or maybe there isn't a class when you
make this the next book is basically how
to understand
the inner workings of an artist and what
those buttons are in their life that can
make them
because once that trust has been broken
or once that
that communication has been
derailed i it's very i don't think it's
something that can come back
did it do the steeple
you know with the hands a lot of this a
lot talking like this
am i doing that right now no no i'm just
i'm just thinking of like you know the
any any good uh movie with an executive
or something you'll have the steeple and
they'll be thinking watch phil watch
phil joanna's film entropy
i think it's a brilliant film phil
phil's a friend uh he directed gridiron
gang um you know phil it's no secret
phil punched out a studio executive in
front of 300 people on a set of heaven's
prisoner
and i think it was heaven's prisoner he
did um it was the alec baldwin film
and
you watch what builds to that point
and a lot of people don't believe that
actually happened i can assure you it
did um and it happens more often than
you realize it may not go to blows as
much anymore i think people are ready
for that now or they they hide behind
text and emails is really what people
are able to do it's that's also a lot of
the face-to-face has been taken out of
our business everything's text messaging
and emails
and you know i think a lot of people do
that out of trying to get it done quick
fear i think fear is a big big component
of that because people don't like
confrontation and i think
you know if executives would just
understand that when you trust an
artist's vision and you greenlight him
or her to
to fulfill that promise
that you you really need to just trust
you you know um
sidney lamet in his book
said something brilliant about
hiring actors and he said when you're a
director and you make a decision on an
actor
good or bad you have to live with that
decision and you have to do everything
you can to see that
that journey is as smooth as sailing as
possible i can't remember the words he
used but there were times in his career
where he said that he really thought he
had the right actor for a role and
realized on day one
in rehearsal that this was the biggest
mistake of his life
and
you would never know it as an audience
member you would never know it as maybe
the actor who he hired but it's it's
about understanding the being that
you're working with and artists are
fragile we're very sensitive to
everything
we take everything personally you know
if somebody doesn't like a cut or
somebody doesn't like
you know the theme of something or the
style
it's it's it's a personal attack it's
never separated
and
it takes a strong artist to be able to
do that and i think it takes a stronger
executive to be able to really find a
way to communicate with people
on how to get the adjustments the studio
or network might need to get what they
need
and i i've really seen it done in a
productive way that's just me sure and i
agree with what you're saying about
being sensitive but i think also too
some of the quote unquote suits and i
wish i could find a better word for them
but um they're also sensitive in that
they don't like being told no
and they don't like people usurping
their authority or or challenging them
especially if they believe in this
pecking order and there's a lot of fear
i think there's fear from both you know
what hollywood fear and love okay so so
fear
fear from both sides and so just
thinking about
what are ways that you know there could
we could prevent a blow-up if if one is
mirrored in a pecking order mindset and
well i can't believe you would tell me
what to do you don't you know who i am
and then there's this artist don't you
know what i've done
and i can't believe you would doubt me
and then the clash that happens yeah
it's ego driven
at the end of the day i mean it's fear
driven and it's ego driven because
you know in our business it's it's
literally you know your career could be
made or broken in in one project you're
either the next
damian chazelle
or
you know you make a mistake and you
don't have a hit you're done i mean you
know
look what happened to george cosmados
you know he came off of god rest him
he's a great filmmaker i mean look at
what tombstone he did tombstone and he
was
you know the next greatest thing and i
worked with him on shadow conspiracy
with charlie sheen which was i think the
last film he ever did and i can assure
you that's not what he wanted to go six
feet under with his name on
and i don't think he would have worked
much after that film no disrespect but
not saying i could do anything better
i'm just saying when you look at how
fast you can turn around you know
you know some great filmmakers and
actors in this industry that have hits
that people just they're just pulled
over with
and
they do a couple more films and what
happens to them and it's unfair
you know one of my favorite filmmakers
of all time is mike vegas i mean i
admire him because here's a guy who
writes directs produces edits composes
caters
you know probably cleans the latrine i
mean that guy is a filmmaker's filmmaker
and obviously when he had leaving las
vegas with
you know nicholas cage and um elizabeth
shu and all the oscar accolades that
came with it
how do you deny somebody like that you
know this guy's gonna do it again you
know solomon king went through the same
thing you know he had a string of hits
and then had some that that weren't as
successful and you know
and it's it's you know i guess it's like
that in sports it's like that in in a
lot of businesses i mean i don't know it
seems like people can in the suit side
it seems like people can run companies
into the ground over and over again and
still
end up running other companies but
we see that a lot but i think i think
the artists and the executives i think
need to
find a way
to
to spend more time understanding one
another and not just thinking they
understand one another
you know we forget that you know i
always go back to the record industry
and and you know when when music was you
know a business back in the earlier days
of a r representatives working for
labels and seeking bands and clubs that
nobody heard of and
watching that that machine grow into
becoming something that was worthy of
signing to a major label
i knew a lot of a r guys back in the 80s
and 90s because of my music background
and i used to say to them you know
how do you not get fired and they say we
say no
you don't sign a band you don't get
fired
and studios have to crank out so many
films a year production companies have
to fulfill the machine especially now
because it's a bottomless pit right you
know
you know how many productions are
getting made at netflix at any given
time it's 33 i think right now
um
so there's a machine that needs to be
filled
but
i think they understand each other from
a very generic standpoint i still don't
think they've found a way to really melt
into
you know harmonious relationships it's
very rare
it's very rare
about a year and a half ago shane you
wrote a book entitled what you don't
learn in film school
so if we proposed a sequel to this book
maybe what they don't teach you after 20
years in the film industry
what would be the main crux of that book
oh that's a great question
um
wow
i think you know as i talk about in the
book
uh every day i learn something new
every day and i i've been producing for
over 30 years and i you know been in
this industry
49 of them and every day i learned
something new
and i i think
what's most important is is whether
you're on the executive side or you're
on the artistic side i think you have to
be open to change
you have to be open to
uh learning from your mistakes and
owning them i think i don't think enough
people
own their mistakes and i think we grow
from our mistakes instead of burying
them and having a fall guy or a
scapegoat i think the biggest thing that
i see is people not learning
um i think i think it goes back to
putting your pride aside you know i've
i've come from a very humble
educational documentary film beginning
and then was very fortunate to to run a
company that did a lot of studio films
and you know ultimately doing gridiron
gang and working with networks and i
have
i have
come back to being an indie guy
and and it's by choice i mean i don't
know maybe nobody wants me in hollywood
proper but i didn't give them the chance
to say they didn't i just decided to go
back to what i love
but what i see in a lot of the people
that i that i come in contact with or i
i work with that are trying to find
their way
is
i think they're more concerned about
public perception about what they do and
how they come off than actually doing
the work
um i find more people spend
most of their time trying to gloat about
what they're doing on social media and
hey i get it it drives drives projects
for some people a lot of people are more
interested in
having you know fake it till you make it
or perception is everything i i get that
i don't i don't endorse it but i
understand it
and i think
what what i find interesting is some of
these filmmakers that i that i
personally know
will
absorb a lot of information whether it's
from me or other people that you've had
on film courage or other filmmakers that
they know that have been through the
good the bad and the ugly
and they love taking the meetings but
they don't apply it
and i'm just as guilty of it i'm not
saying that uh
you know i have all the answers because
i clearly don't um but
i one thing i don't do is i'm you know i
learned to saying when i was in high
school is even a dumb dog doesn't look a
hot stove twice
i try not to do that in what i do i try
to learn and make the next better
you know even if it's just from a
production standpoint last time we were
together i was getting ready to do a
film in the heat of covid you know we
shot that in november december october
november and december of last year in
2020 when other projects were getting
shut down
um we we took over 400 coveted tests we
didn't have one positive
we we had so much fun we had i always
worked with a small crew anyway they
gave us you know with the mandates from
the union we we couldn't have more than
20 people on a set including cast and
crew
it was the most fun i ever had making a
movie in my life
and moving forward i've learned
to take that experience and how i can
make the next project better for for
everybody and it wasn't just about
having a smaller crew or being stuck
doing three tests a week for covid
it was it was about
i think there was a lot of it was people
were so happy to be back out working and
interacting with each other
but it reminded me again of the respect
that we need to have for one another
how blessed we are to be in this
industry whether you're making a 500
film or a 50 million dollar film we are
equally as blessed where we get to do
something we love
and just
trying to remind ourselves it's only a
movie
um i learned something from martin sheen
a hundred years ago we were doing a film
together and it shot over over the
holidays and god god bless him he
he
for some reason he didn't go back for
one of the holidays when everybody else
broke so it was it was adam kane
martin sheen myself and and i think it
was susan mcguire our a.d and the four
of us went out to a holiday dinner
in arizona we were making a film
and he told the story of his heart
attack on apocalypse now you know which
everybody's heard different versions of
it i heard it directly from him and i'm
not going to relay the story i wouldn't
want to waste everybody's time on that
you can research it
but the one thing mr sheen said as he
was being wheeled into the hospital for
his surgery after having his heart
attack
was his wife jan leaned over and looked
at him and said it's only a [ __ ]
movie martin
and here at that time they didn't know
it was going to be one of the most
iconic films in hollywood history
but when when he said that i never
forgot it because what we do is special
to us and hopefully the people that our
work touches and people that see it but
in the grand scheme of life
it's only a movie
and i try to remember that i try to
remember that
when we go on set every day
you know we're blessed to be there have
a smile you're not sitting in a cubicle
trying to raise money and make a movie
you're out making a movie
um
and i i
and again it's it's just
i think the next book going back to your
question of an hour and a half ago karen
i think is
it's bringing a sense of of joy and and
feeling
blessed regardless of what it is you're
doing we all want to do bigger better
things
at a bigger scale and get paid more for
it but it's not about that be in the
moment
love the moment and realize that
you know people only go go to the moon
once usually i don't think there's many
people have been to the moon twice and
and i look at every opportunity to shoot
a film is going to the moon
and
just enjoy the moment build those
relationships
um treat people that you the way you
want to be treated because the day is
going to come or that pa on your set is
going to be the guy running hbo or
you know
uh
three arts entertainment or something
and and you know it's it's mind-blowing
how
going back to what we talked about with
suits and artists it's the way people
treat each other especially in this
business it's not always favorable and
i know i'm not perfect and i've i've
raised my voice and been upset with
people and i like to think i go back and
make it right but i think what i'd like
to see people do is is build more
relationships
and build more of a family within their
core
not just look to get through tuesday get
the film done on time on budget move on
i
think you look at some of the most
successful filmmakers that that have
come through and especially in the old
days and there was a there was a family
you know when hitchcock made his films
people all stepped up and helped each
other there wasn't a divide you know
when he was making psycho and he was
sick and was out for a week or two you
know the ad directed the film his wife
stepped in and did some directing
i mean you know that's that's a family
atmosphere and i i wish there would be
more of that in our industry
and people weren't just interested in me
me me i think it's it's about us
stronger together
you think too
so if we if we took the first book
film school and everyone's about
going out there making their mark and
when you're younger it's definitely more
about competition and wanting to prove
yourself and then
maybe life
has different knocks and different
things happen and it becomes more about
meaning
and so maybe that's also something
that's
you know after
30 years
it's more about what does this project
mean to me and and am i doing what i
want to be doing
i think that's a big part of it um
i think that
if we can grow from everything we do you
know i think that's the key is growth
and and trying to build something
special so the next one is better and
bigger doesn't mean it's going to be
financially bigger or financially better
but the experience and i think when you
have
an atmosphere on a set that people feel
a part of regardless if they're the guys
coming in once a week to empty the
toilets or the star of the show if
people feel a part of something i think
it really shows on screen you know we
talk about that a lot in the book is
temperament respect on a set and how it
ultimately is going to affect your
actors you know they are such sensitive
beings their their antennas are way out
they're picking up on every nuance of of
mood
the director and dp are pissed off at
each other
an ad is upset or snippy they they they
pick up on that
and
you know i just i think what i was
trying to say earlier
is that
i think
i think everybody is truly in our
industry it's every man for themselves
but i think it it shows too much i think
people need to remember that it it takes
a village it takes
it takes a unit
you know we don't we don't
storm countries or go into war thinking
about one or two people we go in as a
unit you know and
i just would like to see more of that in
our industry
what's your advice to people on getting
representation whether it's for film
screenwriting acting
well i think that
um having representation and how it
comes to you and the the need for it is
they're separate you have to keep them
separate i think if you're an actor you
need it
um it's an agent's job is to go through
the breakdowns and submit you for roles
to get you taped auditions are in the
room i mean an actor can't act without
people knowing they exist
i think that cinematographers that's
very important too i think agents can be
very beneficial to a cinematographer's
career
by and large agents sit around wait for
the phone to ring i mean let's call it
like it is the days of agents reading
scripts
taking 20 or 30 home a weekend and
discovering new property and calling an
actor and saying i just read something
you've got to read let's call the
producers and tell them you want to do
this
you know a lot of agents wait for the
phone to ring
and i think that
when
writers directors and filmmakers
ask about getting representation i'm a
firm believer that you're either chasing
it or it's chasing you
and i talk about this a lot in the book
a big chunk of it about representation
and being a filmmaker
and
you know i'm a firm believer that if if
you're not making noise with your work
and you got to call agents and people to
represent you then your work is not
going to be something that they're going
to have a real easy time getting behind
and selling
and i know that's very harsh to say look
i've been through 100 agents and
managers
and i've never gotten a job from one not
one
and i've been with some big agencies and
big managers and maybe it's my fault
maybe i'm just horrible and unsellable
but um i get asked a lot from from young
writers who may have had a short film
made or
producers who are trying to you know
sell sell what they're doing to a bigger
scale
and
you know things today especially with
the changes in our industry in the last
few years
um agencies that are respectable and
real they they're kind of signing people
by committee now it's not
hip-pocketing you know the days of an
agent taking somebody kind of off the
grid in their back pocket and trying to
do something with that is is really
frowned upon
and is something that's really not done
as much anymore if at all
so
when you go in with a with a resume and
a body of work that you might have
uh and try to get representation you you
have to you know they're gonna check
with everybody from the janitor to the
parking attendant to make sure if they
should sign you or not it's it's not
just somebody falling in love with you
and unless it's somebody who runs a
boutique on their own that they are the
judge jury and executioner
but
i have found that when when you seek out
representation and you have to kind of
do a tap dance to get them to want to
get behind your work and your abilities
i always say you know let's see where
that that relationship is in six months
um they usually don't bear much fruit
and and that's
you know uh it's unfortunate it's hard
to get representation as a writer as a
producer as a director in this town that
said it is not hard to create original
content that if it's good enough can get
the attention
of a respectable agent or manager um you
know again we we have endless resources
for so cheap
as filmmakers even even student
filmmakers you know you can get a dslr
you can get actors and again don't hire
your cousin and your mother to be in
them go to acting schools and call the
people that run these acting schools and
say i'm making a short i'm doing a spec
commercial give me some good talent
there are people out there that actually
know how to act that you can get
and
put stuff together if you know if your
hurdle is well i can't get anything done
because i can't get any money or i can't
get anything done because nobody's
behind me then you have to create the
content and if you don't have the
content created how are people going to
know if you're worthy of being
represented or not i'm not
trying to discourage anybody from trying
to get representation and i'm sure there
are those wonderful relationships where
the artist has banged down the door
enough times and the agent finally said
okay i'll rep you and it's it's gone
well there are those exceptions but by
and large
the majority of the time you know
first-time writers and i say first-time
writers i finished a screenplay or i
have a book on amazon
where's my agent it doesn't work that
way
and if it does
you know let's see how that went after
six months i just don't think
that when you have to try to convince
somebody to represent you
um that that that's that's a passion i
think when a true agent
or manager gets behind somebody i think
they have to be passionate about them
i think they have to be they're they're
working for the artist and they have
they only get paid on commission and who
are they going to spend their days
banging down the doors for you know and
if if you're an actor i really believe
you need an agent um but talking about
the filmmaker side it's tough to get
representation and and i
i often tell filmmakers don't don't spin
your wheels and
burn your calories trying to get an
agent just the amount of time you're
trying to burn the phones to find an
agent you should be shooting something
that's going to make an agent say holy
[ __ ] i saw this on youtube i saw this on
you know vimeo i saw this at a film
festival
or at least if you are going to bang on
those doors you should have three or
four
short films or something
you know i know a very successful
commercial director who's who's been at
the top of the game for many years
and i asked him once i said how did you
get in the game you know you didn't come
from film school you didn't have parents
that could you know he said hey man i
got a camera i got i i got friends who
could act i got guys who can hold sound
and i knew how to direct i knew how to
cut
and i went out and i started doing spec
commercials like he did doritos
coca-cola pepsi he would just grab
product and do these incredible you know
how like doritos would have these
contests where you know create your own
create your own campaign and maybe we'll
use it you know he would just do that
for everything he would do cars like if
his mom got a new bmw mom let me let me
make a car commercial for bmw and this
guy had like 20 or 30 commercials
and they all looked like really big
commercials
and he was able to go in and say this is
what i can do this is who you're
representing keep in mind when you go to
an agent they need content to sell you
because they're going to make phone
calls or emails on your behalf and the
decision makers are going to say great
let me see their work and if you don't
have work
the agent's job you're kind of
you're kind of kneecapping the agent
going in because they're going to come
to you and say you got to get me content
and it's it can't be looked at as a
chicken or egg type thing that's an
excuse the filmmaker the artist has to
get out there and and create the content
now if you're a writer
i'm a firm believer that you may you may
excel or be passionate about writing one
thing i think it's important if you're
unknown to really stretch and try to try
to get three or four spec scripts done
in different genres because there are
companies that are just making thrillers
that may read your script that an agent
can take to somebody like mar vista and
and say hey you're doing a bunch of
stuff for a lifetime look at this
if the agent can get it in the room
it'll get a look
but there's also companies that only do
horror there's companies like hallmark
that only do romantic comedies or
whatever those things are called and if
if you're a writer that's looking to get
representation the agent is going to
want
and need as much ammunition as possible
you have to make their job easy and if
you give them three or four different
you know a pallet of different things
they're going to be able to circulate
three or four different scripts and
maybe 15 or 20 different companies think
about what the odds just come
of you not only getting somebody in your
corner to represent you but getting seen
and getting a reputation
a wonderful
woman i met
a year and a half ago at a webinar
right when kovitz started
brilliant writer she writes these
beautiful romantic little you know films
that are just hallmark
and
and and she got she got a script read
and she got a green light and she got
the film produced and now she's a
working writer
and
she
we talked about it and she was like oh
my god i got genres in everything this
woman was pushing a genre but when it
came time to getting looked at and
getting representation she had a whole
plethora of stuff to give to them and
say look i can write anything
and that's what she's doing now and you
have to you know i think too many of us
sit around and wait for the phone to
ring or the door to get knocked on or
somebody to know somebody you have to be
so proactive
on on creating content to get people
excited about what you do i go back to
we talk about films like napoleon
dynamite started as a short saw was a
short
sling blade was a short you know
there's there's so many of those films
even whiplash was a short they obviously
did something right to get the attention
to get these things made into major
motion pictures that hasn't changed
you know people forget that those four
great films started from humble humble
beginnings i mean napoleon dynamite the
short was in black and white for crying
out loud i mean it's horrible but it was
great but it was it was so bad it was
good right
but that's how we have to think as
filmmakers you know james wan did it
brilliantly with his short for saw i
mean i encourage everybody go on youtube
find these films they're all there
they're all there you can find these
shorts and you will see
where billy bob thornton got slingblade
from you will see where you know
napoleon dynamite and whiplash all came
from because they're all they're all
there and they all started because
somebody said screw it i'm gonna do it
and that's that's what i i tell people
they need to do
so maybe we are too much in this mindset
of like i need to have my people do it
oh wait i don't have people i need to
get people i need to get people i i'm i
i'm not successful until i have people
and we're not
willing to say wait a minute i'm not
there yet
a lot of people have a hard time saying
i'm not there yet and that that's a
really good point karen um we all have
to be able to say we're not there yet
and truly identify and accept when we're
not and get over that next hump i mean i
i deal with a lot of actors that you
know
um when we do workshops and and do
acting class you know work and it's
awesome you know i i need a team you
need a team for what you've had an agent
for two years you go out on 15 auditions
a week you're not booking you need to
better the craft do you ever think maybe
you're just not good in a room do you
ever think maybe you need to study
better you know and look at the reel and
half the time they're not off book and
they've had the work for three days and
you're reading one scene you're not off
book yet these are the kind of things
that that really will impact
an actor from getting
past
an audition and it's it's very hard
for artists you know we are so myopic we
are so self-centered anyway it's in our
nature
we we're very selfish people but when it
comes to getting to the next level it's
very very rare that somebody can look
and say it's me
i need to get off my butt and create
content i need to get into acting class
two or three nights a week i need to go
take a class in basic lighting if i
really want to be a cinematographer or a
director i need to understand lenses i
need to you know i tell everybody who
wants to write produce direct
and and get in the edit bay that's where
you're going to learn it more than
anything because you're going to see
you're going to fix other people's
mistakes you're going to you're going to
learn what ends up on a cutting room
floor you're going to realize the amount
of time you waste on a set and what
that'll do is it'll better you when you
make your short films and it'll better
you when when writing scripts i mean
it's amazing how many writers have never
been in the edit bay that's the most
important place you know there are three
scripts there's the one you write the
one that's shot and the one that's cut
and if you can if you can bridge the gap
between the one that's written and the
one that's released boy
you know it's a it's a helpful tool and
i know writers are going to bash me for
saying that but you know get your button
to write in the edit bay and and realize
what what you write and how it affects
you know production costs and you know
putting certain amount of characters in
a certain scene and you got to remember
you got to cover all that get multiple
takes on every actor you know
and and what that does production is a
lot of good you know we talk about this
in other another webinars i've done and
you know the writer needs to understand
a production mindset
because there are some great scripts out
there that that don't get read past 20
or 30 pages and it's because they don't
understand it from a producer view where
you really have to think about when you
write a script you can say well it
shouldn't be that expensive it just
takes place in a flat new york
you know and well okay how many people
are in it you know how many different
locations what is your logistics here
and you have to think of who you're
going after realistically to produce it
and does it fit
in what they're doing
it's about finding that connection with
a producer with your written word
but also kind of going back to what you
said
making an agent's job easier if you have
an agent that isn't wme or caa level
that's not going to kick down doors and
get you to every studio
you got to realize the level of the
agent or manager you're working with and
where they have the ability to get you
now if you are able to
work with somebody and somebody is
showing interest in working with you i
think it's very important you have that
talk early on is what is your ability to
get me through the door what are the
studios networks production shingles
whatever they call them
where can you get my stuff read so that
artist that writer can understand okay
this manager can only get me in a
hallmark so they need to start thinking
about okay let me get this stuff
together for you that's gonna give you
the path of least resistance start
getting my my stuff to you that you can
go to hallmark with or is it lifetime
let me get you some thrillers let me get
you some you know husband came out of
jail wants to see his kid scripts let me
give you some of those and you know and
that's that's important it's not just
about being a good writer it's about
finding a match
and finding out who your potential
representatives have the ability or
juice to get to
so the work that you submit to them
it resonates with the people that it's
ultimately going to get read by because
if you have a great script and the
people that are reading it have no
business making a film like that or no
interest in making a story like that it
doesn't matter it's just wasted time
what if someone says though that i'm not
a diy person like that i i i want my you
know i i'm kind of grew up with staff
and different things so i need i need to
have my people do this well if you've
grown up with staff you should be able
to write checks so write check and go
make a movie i mean that's fine i mean
i'm sorry but yeah i i think you're in
the wrong business i mean it's it's very
rare that somebody can sit in a basement
and just crank out scripts and the day
is going to come where that script is
read by
you know the right agent to the right
assistant to an actor and i mean there's
always the lottery i mean people win the
lottery that's true
you know i think the odds are about the
same but i i think you need to if you're
not diy and you need people and you need
a staff then what i think you need to do
is find other people that are
needing a staff but one of them has a
camera and one of them is an actor and
one of them may be an editor and work
together we talked earlier about people
working together and building something
special and building building a team
everybody having a common goal you know
to get to the next level and that's what
i tell a lot of writers i said you know
the cool thing about being a writer is
you don't need anybody to tell you to go
to work
you really have the only job in this
industry that you you may not get paid
yet
or at all but
nobody can tell you you can't work right
now you have the ability to roll out of
bed turn on a light at two in the
morning and write and that's a beautiful
thing because an actor is not going to
be able to get in front of a camera and
tap dance unless there's a script
director doesn't have anything to direct
unless there's a script there's nothing
to produce without a script the writers
are essential i mean it's so important i
mean it's an incredible position to be
in
if you're not able to be a writer
producer director editor or filmmaker
and all your focus is on writing then
you need to get out more and you need to
find people of like mind that have those
skill sets or the materials to get your
products seen
it's just it's not gonna sitting in a
pdf on an external hard drive or
you know somewhere on your computer is
not going to get it made it's about
getting it with people and i'm very big
you know a lot of people like to talk
about pitch decks and proof of concept
some of the most impressive things i've
seen are
when people go out and shoot a scene or
two or three
to me that's a real pitch deck that's a
proof of concept i don't want to see
papers and comps and actors you're never
going to acquire on your
proof of you know your your pitch deck i
i want to see you go out and shoot a
scene
for your film with comparable qualified
people
and
people that are passionate about it and
i think some of those true pocs that
i've seen they knock me out of my seat i
can't believe what people are putting
together these days
and and i mean for nothing no money
there's no excuse
if you're not pissing someone off you're
not being heard sure
what's the logic behind that
well i think um
i think that
as as artists
i think we're all looking for our voice
i think we're all looking
to
to turn heads
and if you kind of just
fall into the norm and you just kind of
do what everybody thinks you should do
you're not gonna you're not gonna get
the attention you deserve you know you
think about the films that have truly
been game changers or the songs or the
other works of art it's because people
were weren't afraid to
think outside of the box or think left
of left
and and
change scares people we talked earlier
about fear especially with the
executives in this industry and um
i just think that
you know
if
we're coming off of a time
where there's been so much hatred passed
back and forth especially on social
media between different sides of the
fence right and at the end of the day
we're all humans we need to we need to
unite
but
what what is apparent is
if you just follow
like sheep and just kind of go about
your merry way you're just you're gonna
you're gonna fit nicely into a mold and
they're gonna compartmentalize you and i
think some of the artists that i've
respected most
they're not afraid of pissing people off
and making change and making success
come their way because they weren't
afraid to to rub people the wrong way
they weren't afraid to give somebody the
big fu
and say i'm doing it this way and i
don't need your money i don't need your
distribution we're just gonna go do it i
mean you know robert rodriguez is a
classic example dennis hopper you know
when him and peter fonda went out and
did easy rider you know some of the
people that i admire as filmmakers i
mean you know looking at somebody
like hal needham um
who you know
came from a tough stuntman background
and understood the workings of how to
make a movie you know breaking them down
from shot to shot to working with the
editors the producers the directors the
actors the stuntmen and finally just
woke up one day and started making these
great movies
and you know i'm inspired most by rebels
i'm inspired most by people that
weren't afraid if people were going to
approve doesn't mean you're going to be
successful
but
you know
i think
i think there's certain things as
artists that that we have a
responsibility to do i mean art is what
changes the world
um movies
movies hollywood songs they
they set the tone for culture they
change trends you know like that and
that's
exciting to me
and you know what when you hear me say
if you're not pissing people off you're
not being heard well if you're just
falling into what everybody else is
doing you're just falling into what
everybody else is doing you know quentin
tarantino became who he was because he
did things his way
he he was willing to roll the dice and
fortunately found people that were
willing to roll the dice with him you
know robert rodriguez mike figgis we
talked about him earlier
dennis hopper i'll need him i mean some
of these great filmmakers that just
they're not afraid to rub people wrong
they're not afraid to piss people off
they're not afraid to fail they're going
to go down and a ball of flames are
going to do it their way
but man
if it works watch out
and that just is kind of that mindset
so maybe it doesn't mean deliberately
trying to piss people off but
but knowing that they're going to be
people that are going to be offended or
a they themselves feel they can't do
that so they don't want you
to do it because absolutely their social
structure wouldn't approve them oh
absolutely i mean i can't tell you how
many times
i would get calls
um
from people that i had produced with in
the past
that would say to me you know
i i'm really concerned that
this investor may go on imdb and see
some of the things you've done in the
past whether it was with zalman king
or charlie sheen or whatever and i'm
like
yeah okay so what's the problem
you know if they've had a pretty good
run
and you know it's this fear and of you
know maybe certain people would be
nervous or whatever and i i never
understood that i i would always ask him
to please explain that to me
you know charlie somebody i was very
proud of having a history with
uh in my career and is very instrumental
in getting me to where i am in my life
and
for somebody to come along and and be
nervous about the rebellion of of a
charlie sheen or a bad boy
and and somebody who who made some of
the most incredible erotic cinemas
almond king
and you know those are people that
basically gave people the middle finger
and did what they wanted to do i mean
one of my favorite solomon king stories
and we didn't talk about this before we
talked about suits and artists
was i remember working with zalman on a
film
and an executive from the studio was
there we were on the other side of the
world we were in bali indonesia and
there was somebody there telling him how
something had to be done and he
oh absolutely it went through this whole
dog and pony show that was so unsolvent
at the time
and the guy left you just turn around
and goes [ __ ] him he goes watch how we
do this and he goes you got to remember
something he goes if you're going to if
you're going to do something you do it
your way you just got to learn how to
tap dance and tell people what they want
to hear so they give you the opportunity
to do it because remember if you screw
up you're done
but if you're successful
they'll take the credit for it but
you'll work again
and you know that's that's kind of it i
just you know i i just i went through a
phase where
i was getting calls from a lot of
i don't know more prim and proper
entities that
weren't much into
the mentality of just going out and
doing what you want to do everything was
very structured everything was very
formulaic which is not something that i
fall well into
and
i just found that there was a lot of
things that they were trying to
to reshape
or curb or
you know kind of
protect
from certain people they were involved
with knowing it's like well you know
there is something called the internet
it's all out there you know
but my point is is that i i learned
really quickly that there there are a
lot of people that as you said it's fear
they they're afraid
of
being looked at as a rebel or somebody
likes to kick the dirt or whatever and i
i personally don't don't care i
personally don't care you know do what
you want do what you love love what you
do and and do what feels right in here
as long as you're not hurting anybody
and if it pisses people off say the
video well good i'm glad i got some free
rent in your head
you think people are scared of that
personality type because it can't be
controlled
i i think there's
i you know i think it's not about
trying to be rebellious or being
controlled i think yeah there's a lot of
people that want to try to conform you
especially as artists into what they
want you to be or what their end game is
um i think a lot of there's so many
intricate parts in filmmaking you know
there are people that bridge the money
together with the product and then the
product with the artist and then the
artist with the output and there's so
many people that have to be kept happy
and again it goes back to i think
executives and artists being able to
learn how to communicate better better
lines of communication and understanding
each other better
but i think that
there's a lot of fear and and we've been
fortunate in working with people in in
our circle that the decision makers that
come at our end who are the ones writing
our checks
they they love what we do they get what
we do and they trust us
and
they say we're doing this because we
believe in you we're doing this because
we like what you do and what you
represent so go do it and and that's it
doesn't matter if they're giving you
five dollars for a film or five million
for a film it's just about
working with people who understand you
and if if you're a true artist and there
are things that you want to
express there's things that you want to
experiment with
i think you need to
respect yourself enough to do that i'm
all for doing work to get paid you know
that we've all been works for hire
things that we wouldn't put on our
resume or maybe things that we're not
excited about there's nothing wrong go
work every time you work you're going to
learn every time you get another credit
you know you'll put some groceries away
in the in the cupboards and you get to
eat and it's fun you get to pay rent and
all that fun stuff but
i think you also have to remember to
allow yourself that freedom and to be
able to do that and i think yeah there's
a lot of people that are afraid i know i
was working with somebody in the past
that was
working with some entities that were not
exciting to me and there was there was a
concern about
what i represented as a filmmaker what
my attitude is and making the films that
i want to make and where they were
thriving and other networks and other
outlets that were like oil and water and
i finally got to the point i was like
you got to pick a side you know you're
either going to you're going to do what
i do or you're going to keep doing that
which no disrespect that's that's cool
pays your bills but if you're going to
come here you're not going to stifle
what i do
hoping that these other entities are not
offended because you're affiliated with
me i don't embarrass anybody i'm not
gonna
you know kill puppies or beat children
but there is certain types of
mentalities mindsets and content that we
make that may not fit
on the family channel and that's just
not kind of content i want to make
so
yeah i think there's a lot of people who
try to stifle and try to conform artists
into being what they want them to be
for the wrong reasons and that's that's
to me is you know that can be very
dangerous for the artist
did you watch the queen's gambit
i actually did
i was afraid you're gonna ask me if i
saw something which i didn't see oh okay
thank you thank you for not asking if i
saw bridgerton okay sure so so forgive
me i'm blanking on the character's name
but thomas brodie sanctuary sangster if
i i hope i'm saying his name right so
the one that's like this rebel chess
player who kind of saunters him he's
kind of the james dean right
yeah and then once you finally get to
know him he's actually a sweetheart
but he has this mystique and this
persona of this bad boy chess player
amongst some very cookie cutter
intellectual overthinking
you know stanford graduates right
exactly smart people smart people but
but also very invested in their
identities as smart people yeah and so
this guy comes in and he's just like
this
you don't know what to make of them
you're fascinated by them but anyway so
i just it kind of reminds me of that i
just that's a great analogy it was a
great show we really enjoyed that i
think like the rest of the world we
caught that during covet we didn't buy a
chess set afterwards um but
uh yeah and you know i think there are
ways and i hate to keep bringing them up
and and i owe so much of my career to
zulman zalman king if you don't know who
he is look him up
um zolman took me under his wing you
know 25 years ago
and
i learned more from my my years with
zalman than anybody
and zalman was a true rebel i mean he
was a golden globe nominated actor
turned writer who wrote you know nine
and a half weeks with his wife
and
and went on to direct some of the most
incredible incredible cinema
um
and nobody told a story through a lens
like solomon nobody could
and the careers he launched and
discovered are endless whether you talk
about mickey rourke or kim bassinger
you know david david duchovny and uh
just that the list goes on and on and on
and my point is solomon had a
relationship his partner
was it was a man who i still am very
close to by the name of david saunders
david david was running
one of the the sub studios under sony
when peter gruber was there and zalman
and this suit
became friends and they wound up
creating red shoe diaries
and launching show timing that was
really their first series
and built an empire on this this
incredible series starring a guy that
nobody knew about called david duchovny
that you know just opened the letters
and read them and read them to his dog
usually and made these incredible women
empowering erotic cinema
the relationship that i most admired of
all the relationships i've known in
hollywood was solomon and david
and just talk about mutt and jeff
you know apples and ford trucks ying and
yang
and boy were they were they
that's the kind of relationship
executives and and artists should have
because they they conquered the world i
mean you may not like what they did but
they conquered the world
yeah i think each needs each other
because because one is going to have one
skill set that the other doesn't have
and vice versa and absolutely one will
be organized one will be sort of a
beautiful
yeah and they need each other
and they really they really fed off of
one another and there was nobody better
in the room they would fight like cats
and dogs i remember you know david
duchovny said when solomon passed that
he was a true artist he'd think more
about the curtains in the room and the
color and the sheen they would give off
off a certain light at the certain time
of day he would shoot at zollo would
focus on that for hours and then you
know want something painted a certain
color and dave would come in and say
whoa whoa whoa back up how much money
are you spending on painting these
things you know how much you spending on
this fabrics element well well that's
that's insane you can't do it they'd
fight well then ethan i'm not doing a
movie david like me sorry shane movie's
canceled have a good life you know i
just slowly go for a walk i knew they'd
fix it and they always did they did that
you know almost every day but they were
an incredible duel duo and uh
that's the kind of relationship that i i
wish for artists to have with somebody
because they they really david was the
business and zolman was the artist and
boy did they just they were
amazing is it a producer's job to gather
ip
well
i i would think so i mean you know
you know neil moritz uh who who is the
the master behind fast and the furious
you know
you think about how that that incredible
franchise was birthed off of an article
in the back of the metro and the la
times i think it was a metro section or
valley section about subculture of
street racing and those cars and
that's what a great producer does is
they comb articles you know a lot of
lazy ones like to watch 2020 or dateline
those things usually don't get made into
movies if they do they
they only go so far
um
i find that some of the great producers
that i've been fortunate enough to know
are the ones that would give me the time
of day to at least you know talk to
it's these these these guys are on the
hunt they are constantly looking for a
needle in a haystack
you know whether it's neil moritz or
david hayman or
you know david zillon i mean they're
just constantly looking
looking and looking
for that thing that just knocks them
over
and
i think good producers don't wait for it
to come to them i think it's a
producer's job to you know i we talked
about the music industry earlier what
made what made a great
record executive and it was the ones
that went to the nightclubs you know the
roxy the whiskey and the gizarri's at
two o'clock
you know on a monday night and watch
that headlining band on a monday or
tuesday that's that's where bands like
van halen were found and you know i know
i know their history but i'm just saying
that they were signed off of a really
crappy
attended night
on the strip on a weeknight and
i think producers need to be more
proactive i think you know we we have
gotten to the point where
it's we are so used to everything being
at our fingertips we can research
everything we you know instant
gratification and i think the days you
know i mean there i remember when when i
knew neil moritz years ago long before
we did gridiron gang together
i never saw neil without scripts
you know
i mean every time you saw neil he had
scripts he was always reading
that guy was just constantly he was a
sponge for content
and you know it paid off look at the
career he's had i mean the guy's doing
everything
and um it's about finding those you know
those books that nobody
has the rights to that you that you see
wow this can this this ip can change the
world and you know i'd be careful
um
you know if if it's successful it's
probably owned
but i think there are some gems out
there that are waiting to be found that
you know it's always nice when a
producer especially somebody younger or
newer or somebody who may be more green
or
not have the deep pockets that some of
these these folks have to be able to
find something and create it and and get
it made
but i think it's it's a producer's job
that's if you're going to produ you know
there's two kinds of producers there's
they're the ones that find the ip raise
the money get the distribution and the
stars attach and then there's the the
producers that are you know more line
producers that are on the film that are
you know hiring the crew and getting the
locations and getting all the vendors
and gear and
everything done
but
you know when you talk about a producer
who is going to do the suit side of the
job
uh if you will
um
i think it's just so important to just
be a sponge be open to
anything and everything you just never
know where you're gonna find that
that that thing
you know
and how would one know if
the rights are owned whether it's life
story rights or there's actually a
script or yeah you know in
acquiring property is
several different ways you can do it i
mean if one of the one of the biggest
passion pieces i have that i swear i'm
going to get made before i die
is the kelly sutton story i mean here's
a woman who held the
speed record at daytona who's living
with multiple sclerosis i mean she was
supposed to die when she was eight years
old she's cheated death seven times i
think she's been a widow three times
over
her story is unbelievable um i was
shooting a documentary in in wyoming in
montana when the whole world was on fire
up there back in like a 102 and i was
sitting in a holiday inn and we were we
were basically being kept in a hotel
because of the fire danger
and i i had nothing to do the tvs were
out the electricity was out and i went
to the lobby of the hotel and i found
this sports illustrated and there was a
tiny little sub article you know you
could read through the magazines and
they've sometimes got a little sub
something on the side and and it said
she'll she'll stop at nothing that was
the name of the article and it was about
kelly girl sutton
and
it was
three paragraphs from paragraphs along
it was the most incredible piece i'd
ever read
i got home i reached out to the family
to nascar i found her you know the
internet wasn't as amazing back then was
able to find her talk to her parents got
in touch with kelly flew out to a race
watched her race a nascar event
and uh
such a wonderful human being
and
one of the one of the most delightful
business relationships i've had you know
i i feel like
we've failed we haven't gotten the
filmmade yet we came very close a couple
times
had a green light at a network that an
agent was good enough to ruin agents are
good at that
um
but
that
when you
find somebody's story that you want to
tell if you're a producer i think the
most important thing that you you need
to do is
is is be humble you know a lot of people
in our industry go to people with hype
and pomp and circumstance with all the
promises you know and well look when
somebody's story is breaking news like
the little girl that fell into well 30
years ago
every studio in hollywood's going to try
to get that you know so
step aside you're not getting those
rights chances are
but
you know if you find something that you
like as an article in the back of a
three-year-old sports illustrated or you
see a piece on tv or you caught a news
segment
you know i always say reach out as
humble as possible and just say look i i
fell in love with your story i want to
tell your story and i want to see it's
told in a way that you can be proud of
that will represent you and your family
um and just go in with with with a
servant's heart
i've been fortunate to to own a lot of
intellectual properties of life rights
you know whether it was rick and dicky
hoyt story or you know
the great iron gang that's one
that we had
um
it's just it's about
being kind it's about being gentle it's
not about selling the hype you know a
lot of people go into those things not
realizing that the people that they're
approaching are not hollywood people
so
they're very off put by our energy often
you know whether we call it passion or
pomp and circumstance or just a bunch of
[ __ ] i don't know but
we tend to go in
on 10. a lot of these people have often
just gone through a pretty dramatic
situation in their life or a pretty
extraordinary situation they're being
courted by all sorts of people or
getting all sorts of press that they're
not used to
and i think you know it's important to
remember that these people are not of
our world
in business
there are ways to
try to penetrate their
their their world and not be
you know intrusive
great way to get ip though
is to scour articles oh articles
datelines you know 2020s
you get to a point that where a lot of
executives will start hearing things and
they'll say it sounds like a dateline it
sounds like a 2020 story you know things
are probably better served there but
there are some remarkable stories that
come out of them there really are i mean
i fell in love with the bruce murakami
story i don't think everybody remembers
that where
poor gentleman was you know his his wife
and two children got into a minivan and
went to the store and they were they
were t-boned by a street racer killed a
wife and two kids
and um
the kid was going to go to prison and
bruce stepped in and asked for mercy
from the court
it was the ultimate story of compassion
and trying to change a life instead of
sending a 16 year old kid to prison for
10 years
i'm going to take this kid under my wing
i'm going to
and
i i saw it on dateline or 2020 like 20
years ago
bruce flew out met with him and
i really liked bruce a lot but he was
also being courted by everybody else
film ended up getting made i think with
dean kane and lifetime or something but
it was it was one of those things you
knew it was going to get made
you know
it's interesting but uh you know yeah
it's about
you're basically pitching you
as a filmmaker you know we talk about
writers going into the roman pitching
and
you may not be a writer if you're a
producer but you have to meet the family
or the survivors
people that have gone through some
extraordinary circumstances and try to
pitch them on feeling comfortable with
you i mean you're selling them on you
and your game plan and your tone and
temperament
when did you realize you had to
transition away from screenwriting i was
horrible at it
i mean you know
it wasn't i i just you know
i i i worked as a screenwriter for a
number of years i was very fortunate
um i was more passionate about being on
set and working with people i'm a people
person at the end of the day it's one of
my many faults
and when you're a writer you're you're
isolated you're locked up and you're
that way too as an editor which i still
get stuck doing
but
it's it's more interaction um
you know but
i just i just got to the point that you
know i as i got older and realized where
my passions were and my energies were
and my strengths and weaknesses were
writing just i started working with you
know
people you know i work a lot with cj
wally i just when i read his work it
made me want to make movies again i was
i was done you know
i was ready to phone you know be done
do the book go teach i had a teaching
opportunity at a university to come in
and
i i read a script that cj wrote and i
said this guy makes me want to
keep making movies
and i realized that this this guy can
tell the stories that kind of stories i
want to tell and we collaborated really
well together
and you know it's exciting when you read
somebody's work that inspires you to
keep going because i was you know i was
tired i had been beating a bag a long
time and
kind of thought you know
i've been very fortunate i've been very
blessed i made my mark good bad and
different i made a mark may have been a
stain in some people's eyes but i made
one
and i wanted to teach and inspire and
encourage the next generation and and i
just i just felt that the amount of time
it took to write
and it wasn't allowing me to make a film
a year or two films a year the way i
wanted to
and
it's great to work with somebody who
understands and gets me knows how to
write for schedule and budget
we want to tell the same stories
i don't need to do that anymore
what's it like having
written and developed your own work now
hiring writers or partnering with other
writers to tell those stories
well you know it's it's nice to be able
to
focus
on on certain things and not spread out
too thin you know write produce direct
edit
get the financing all that stuff it's it
really is it's a taxing business i mean
this business will eat you up even if
you have one job
and you know spending the years writing
and developing something and trying to
get it financed and get it produced
um it takes a lot of time and and i kind
of go back to having the ability to work
with somebody who we we both want to
tell the same stories we both want to
make
fun action comedy action thriller female
driven let the guys sit in in the
passenger seat let the girls drive
make these fun films
and
we we both
love the same kind of movies we're both
inspired by the same kind of movies you
know going back to like the old hal
needham films you know dirt movies and
you know
fast cars you know race against time
cannonball run
smoking a bandit you know
and it's just it's easy it's it's it's
almost like we don't it's like hey we're
gonna line up to do another one
what do you think about this
interesting okay what if we did that
it's a very
simple process that the long part of it
is you know cj in our situation cj will
just go through the whole breakdown and
develop development notes and
you know basically block it out
you know and then once that's done the
scripts come very fast it's a very fast
process like we did double threat that
was created in
mid-september we were shooting that by
october 15th i mean we had a script in
six days
you know we all knew the story we wanted
to tell it was just about going out and
rolling a dice during covet and doing
and as i said earlier was the most fun
i've ever had making a movie
and i hope i hope that translates on the
screen we had a lot of fun
how many writers do you have working for
you now i work with
uh cj wally is is you know my point
we're doing a lot of stuff together
right now
uh but i'm a big fan of wt smith's work
we've we've done some specs together
over the years i think he's such a
brilliant writer
um he's poetic and every breath
and every every space between a word is
just it's it's magic he's a brilliant
writer
um nicole faire brother is is a writer
that i
i was fortunate enough to find she's up
in canada she's a lovely writer
i'm a big fan of her work i hope to do
stuff with her someday
but right now i'm primarily working with
cj because we have a slate of projects
that we're doing that we have a
commitment on that we have to do
and it's exciting it's fun how many
years have you worked with the same
writers
well
you know i um
i've worked with with w.t smith off and
on for like 10 years we've collaborated
he's he's done some amazing work
um and
i've worked with cj now i think we're
going on year
i think we're hitting year four
three or four
you know i see i see working with
writers it's like a marriage
um
you know it's a lot a lot like a dp in a
director's relationship i think if you
if you start it off
in in a certain
synchronicity you know carry that out
through the end and you know cj's become
a producer partner um
he doesn't just write but you know he's
so involved in what we do and you know
we cut the films and i like getting him
involved
because you know as we talked about
earlier i am a firm believer there are
three scripts there's the one that's
written the one that's shot and the one
that's cut
and we we get every time we get closer
and closer to writing a cut film
but you know there's also a respect
factor that i have you know it's funny
when we first met
he was shocked that i wanted him to come
out from london to be on set when we did
break even
you know like
why wouldn't the writer be there
you know and the writer's standpoint was
well we're never invited out you know
it's we got the script we got what we
wanted from you thank you you'll see the
film when it's done and
i just think you know when somebody
births something creates something
i think they become a very
important part of the entire process i
think it's a respect level
there are times where you know we have
to cut films down because of
distribution deals where
you know
television is going to only allow so
much time you know we're not getting 3
500 screens we're not quentin tarantino
we can make these three hour
movies about hollywood or whatever and i
love his work i'm just saying that you
don't have that ability we have to keep
our films under 95 minutes
well you shoot the script and you glue
it together and you've got
you know two hours you got 30 minutes
you got to rip out you know who better
to ask than than than the writer at
first to say hey look we're 30 minutes
over man let's start talking about what
can go instead of just hacking it away
and maybe not being as sensitive to some
of the nuances or subtleties that were
planted early on
and i made that mistake in not involving
a writer on those edits and
that's something that i wouldn't do
again you know it's just sometimes the
distributors come in and say well we
love it we're going to take it out but
you got to shorten it by 20 minutes and
you just you're in a hurry everybody
thinks they know where the best places
to hack are
i think it's good to involve the writer
smart
we understand your strategy is to
develop a log line and a synopsis
and will you try to pitch investors
first or the distributors
you're asking me personally
um
i often will come up for me a title is
important i i get stuck in a mud without
a cool title
my movies may suck but our titles are
cool
and i need that that gives me some fuel
we know the stories we want to tell
um
and
synopsises
we come up with a with an idea what
what's what's our idea what's the story
and that inspires it and we just start
you know who who are the players who are
the protagonist antagonists who are the
you know what's the hero's journey what
are their what are their pitfalls and
hurdles gonna be
you know what's what's the ticking time
bomb what's gnawing at them
and then we we go through it and you
know break it down and start doing our
development notes and
and
when i get excited about it i call our
investors and i say you know
we're ready
you know we're ready to go and we know
the story we want to tell and usually
it's just a paragraph that they want
from us um
you know
th that's at least in our situation
that's what we do we we get to do what
we want to do we're very fortunate
so we there's it's it's pretty much
coming up with the story we want to tell
and going and doing it and and let chips
fall where they may
you know it kind of comes back to
doing things the way you want to do them
and
not
not allowing people to tell you how to
do things or why do you think we're open
to you know suggestions and stuff but we
tell the stories we want to tell and we
cast the people we want to cast and we
make the movies we want to make
and we don't ask for permission
so if the title is very important to you
how much back and forth and
disagreements have you had over titles
and has that
put the kibosh on
the beginning
it's already cut off titles have never
been a problem that's that's one thing
that i often come up with um the film
that we're starting in september
we
we we had about a five second clash on a
title there were two titles that we both
liked
and
[Music]
we're going with
the other one and the more i think about
it the more cool i am with it but
um titles it's never been a problem i
just when i was writing i needed a title
i needed a title to get excited if i
didn't have i couldn't be i couldn't get
excited about it
i needed to get excited about
blowing smoke i need to get excited
about you know
double threat i need to get excited
about breakeven i needed once i had a
title i can just that's all i need and i
can just i'm all in
give me that title and i'm all in you
know at least in my world it's just so
important to me
you know it's everything it's everything
and it doesn't mean my titles are great
but at least to me they are right i mean
we all love our children
so the untitled shane stanley project is
not going to work for you no you can't
no
get out of bed at 2 am to start typing
for that no
no
does not
there are there are no untitled shane
stanley scripts or projects i promise
you it has to have a title if it's going
to get the time of day from me
yeah
it's really important and you seem to
like shorter titles or no i think
they're easier for people to remember
[Laughter]
i you know i mean
i i'm not saying all the titles that
i've had
are winners at the end of the day but i
learned early you know i did a couple of
films with avi lerner back in the day
and
because he sold globally
titles were so important i learned that
titles have to translate globally you
know we can come up with the greatest
title in the world if that doesn't
translate into 14 different languages
it's not a good title and that's really
important and
you know something that people can
remember something that people say often
you know
people say i break even you know they're
a double threat
you know oh he's just blowing smoke you
know those are the kind of titles that
that appeal to me
a lot
you know that's just me personally but i
remember that i remember when i was
working with avi when blockbuster and
hollywood video were still a thing
he used to say
when you come up with a title
it's important to remember people are
going to start at new releases at a and
they're going to work their way to z
most people are done choosing by the
time we get to m
which is funny our most successful film
was with an n no code of conduct with
avi but
that was just kind of his model in
coming up with titles
so i never forgot that
and people laugh at me when i throw that
out because i like blockbuster what and
it's different now because everything's
on a thumbnail everybody's you know
checking stuff online or gets promoted
and doesn't matter but that was obvi's
mentality and you think about the
success avi lerner has had over the last
30 or 40 years as being one of the most
prolific independent filmmakers in
history
um
okay that's some advice i learned from
avi that's one thing i'll take away from
that relationship
yeah so titles are important something
catchy quick simple
you know what is the three billboards
outside of ebbing's montana i mean but
that worked it worked but what did
everybody call it i don't know three
billboards okay yeah you see throw both
three that's a tongue twister right
had you seen billboards yet that's what
i remember
yeah do you always go to a distributor
first with your idea um i i run it buy
them
i'll run it by him you know i have a
good relationship with with a
distributor that um
that we have and i i just tell them this
is what we're doing i mean i i i don't
mean that
i just i i we go make the films we want
to make people can catch it or they they
don't have to
um
we're at a point
where
i don't care if it's it's going in the
dirt with 50 grand and a couple of
stolen cameras and we're going to shoot
our movie you know fortunately we
haven't had to do that yet but i would
that's what we were going to do with
double threat during covet we literally
had 50 grand offered to us to do
something during covid
and we were we were all in and we got
fortunate and
one of our backers was excited to hear
we wanted to do something
and said no let's let's do it right but
that's our mentality we just want to
make movies go find a home
they'll find a home
so
you know it takes time to get to that
point and it's it's it's just being able
to do the things you want with the
people you love and the people that are
behind you whether they're writing the
check or putting the film out get what
you do and they know what they're gonna
they know what to expect with us
they know what they're gonna get
so
you know
it's i talked to a distributor the other
day and it was
oh you're making a movie when do you
start september 28th oh would you do you
want to tell us what this one is
oh i can't sure
you know
that was a discussion we're making it
anyway
hope you enjoy
it
will you ever have a full screenplay
written when you pitch distributors or
only the idea i'm not gonna talk to a
distributor until i'm financed
so i mean that's just me personally i
i'm not gonna waste anybody's time i'm
not gonna call an actor i'm not going to
call
anybody until we're you know at this
point where it's like okay yeah we can
make a movie
um
often
who reads scripts anymore i mean you
can't get agents to read them lord knows
they don't do that you know are
distributors really going to read a
script no they want to see a dumb movie
they want to know what you're doing
you know they're just going to throw it
to somebody for coverage
and if you're making your movies based
on coverage i think that's a bad thing
some of the greatest movies in history
got covered so poorly some of the worst
moves in history are some of the
greatest coverage films i mean it's it's
you know it's who's reading and who's
covering
um sometimes coverage is done out of
respect while somebody will say well we
want to take this out
um we'd like to take a look at it and
get some coverage on it okay and they
usually call back so you checked all the
boxes it's it's fine go go have fun go
do it but that's it's not how we make
movies it's it's not about committee it
takes a team
but
we our job is to make the film and it's
not our job to distribute or sell it and
we have a mutual respect where
you know what you're going to get when
we do something and i know what to
expect from you when you're going to put
it out and i won't tell you how do you
do your job let me do mine
and that's the relationships that we
like to have with our distributors and
sales agents and
it's just it's just you know it comes
from time time and time it's been
beating the bag for you know producing
films for over 30 years you
you can
you know get to a situation with some
people that are willing to trust you and
it's about trust it's about doing films
and another reason i'm an indie rat
is i like i don't i don't put our
investors at risk you know make the
movie for what it can get made for
so the the the stakes are low so people
aren't you know you're not ending up
wearing cement shoes in two years
because you know couldn't give something
away that cost millions of dollars it
happens all the time that's not how we
make our movies we make our movies we
punch way above our weight class we we
weigh our kick our punk coverage on
these things we get great cast great
crew we make them look as good as we can
it's a roger corman idea it's the same
mentality i mean how many films did
roger corbin kick out
you know
it's it's just about doing what we love
and getting them done and
having fun
and giving giving people content
that's our job
and um i i don't like to over complicate
it i i will
i will never
go to a distributor without a script i
mean there's nothing to talk about if
there's no money you know i i don't talk
to them until it's it's we're financed
we're ready to go and then
we're making it
that's just that's just the timeline of
what we do now
when you were making movies with charlie
sheen at that time how much did it cost
to make them and how much were the
distributors paying you for the movies
back when we were doing those um
we were an independent company that that
kind of decided to do its own content
it's kind of the early
working with some of the majors but
getting a real taste of independent
filmmaking
um
we were really in a fortune fortunate
situation because charlie was a movie
star you know he had just come off
things like terminal velocity and shadow
conspiracy and
you know the arrival and his incredible
catalog of work
and so we we had the avi learners
coming to us saying
we'll we'll give you up to 10 to 12
million to go make a movie
and so
they weren't distributors that were
buying them they were people like avi
that obviously would you know smart
businessman he would he would cast it
with real players and go sell it at can
or afm before we even shot a foot of
film i remember we went to cannes
for the 50th anniversary and they put us
up at the hotel do cop and um
we had a press conference and it was
mock artwork of the film with charlie
sheen mark de coskos
joe lando martin sheen
and
you know they pre-sold that thing
globally i'm sure for a lot more than
they gave us to make it the film did
very well
um miramax dimension actually ended up
picking it up
and they made some good tv deals on it
and
we made the film for 12. we actually
made it for nine because we shot it in
arizona at the time they at the time had
a 30
rebate so we got i think three million
back in actual cash rebate wasn't tax
incentives it was cash rebate
and
that's how movies used to be made
especially in such a huge home video
market that was the height of
blockbuster and you know
hollywood video and all those great you
know brick and mortar mod pasta stores
were just they
they were printing money because of the
home video market and dvds coming out
blu-ray hadn't hit yet so they were
giving us a lot of money you know we
were making some of these indie films
for 8 to 12 million
those were good times those were really
good times
how much easier was it to make movies in
the 90s
well
i don't know if it was easier um
[Music]
there when we were making them you know
the budgets were big we were able to
kick out a couple a year um
and again the home video market was so
was so big you know you were able to get
territories to put up a lot of money
around the globe for the home video
market tv rights foreign theatrical you
know things have changed substantially
um i find it easier to make movies now
because we're able to make movies for a
lot less i mean we're shooting all those
movies on panavision 35 millimeter
cameras you know that camera package to
rent that film to to buy and process and
tell us any and convert to video you
know digital format so you can cut it on
your avids which back then cost 180 000
you know it movies were expensive back
then
uh we weren't making them for cheap
um it's just you know
and we were doing independent films and
you know i cringe today when i hear
about independent movies that are like
five million dollars i think that's no
indy you know five million dollars in
today's economy be great that the toys
that we have that we can make movies for
but back then we were doing the indies
for you know eight to 12 million
what should a filmmaker use to determine
a budget whatever he can get
and i mean that i i'm a big proponent
of what's your budget who cares i
you know so many of us
it's it's about a budget you know you
can get it broken down six ways till
sunday 10 different line producers break
it down budget it you can use all your
different pay scales with the unions and
whatnot
that's all that's all going to be black
and white
but at the end of the day what's
stopping you from getting the movie made
so for me
i don't think about
what a budget has to be i think about i
always put my investor first i always
think what's going to put he or she at
the lowest risk
how do we execute this to the best of
our ability so we can out kick our punt
coverage we can now punch our weight
class puts put it all on the screen and
wow people for a fraction of what people
think we actually made it for that's
just my mentality doesn't mean it's
right for everybody so when i look at a
project
an investor calls me and says we're
ready to go or i call them and say i'm
ready to go what's your comfort level
for the next season and they tell me um
i say okay this is how much we have what
can we do with this
i i kind of go into it bass backwards
and i i just i
i watch filmmakers
time and time again not get movies made
because they've set some some budget in
their mind and unless you're being given
the money by a studio or a network who
is really governing that that's what the
budget has to be
um
you know my father
tried for four years to get desperate
passage made he had a million dollar
budget back in 1980
well it started in 82. so a million
dollars was a lot of money back then
finally in 1985 86 he got 25 grand to go
make the movie that was you know cutting
really short to the chase on this story
and
my my mother my father and i with a
couple of
tight filmmaker friends we we huddled
together and figured out how we were
going to do it and i don't think the
film
would have been at all different if we
had had the million versus the 25.
i don't think a frame of the film would
have been any different
and the success that that film had it
taught me how to make movies for nothing
and you know what it launched
you know ultimately gridiron gang and a
lot of you know seven other movies of
the week that collectively did very well
that all came from a 25 000 let's do
this from a million dollar budget so for
me
i always tell a filmmaker
what do you have access to
what are your means if you're going to
write the check yourself
what can you afford how can you do this
really break it down let's not think
about putting all the money in your
pocket let's think about building
content are you going to be able to own
the library when it's all said and done
it's become a valuable asset to you 20
years from now
and i think it just you know in most of
the
the the talks that we give with with
producers and webinars it's it's
the main reason people are not making
their content is because they can't
raise the money that they've this
self-imposed budget
and i just think sometimes if they they
really
really learn the craft of of how to get
things done
and not chins out on what your ultimate
vision is i mean it's not about
cheapening out or chinsing out okay sure
you're not going to get george clooney
on a 500 000 budget versus a 50 million
budget but
is you trying to get that 50 million
dollars gonna be ten years from now you
talking about getting that movie made
still or have you moved on to five other
movies you still haven't made and and
for me it's about
getting excited about making a project
and doing everything you can to get it
done and okay this is what we have to do
it we're getting it done for this let's
go and that that's probably one reason
that i that i have the career i have
where it's
it's not about the budget and what it
has to be it's this is what we can do
our next project for let's create this
content for this budget
and and every project you do is going to
build you to another level whether it's
dollars or actor level or distribution
or whatever you have to look at you know
this this industry
we we hear about the success stories but
for for most of us it's truly a marathon
it's not a sprint and you have to look
long-term it's like you know when you
put money into a cd or an ira it's
long-term growth and you have to look at
this career like that because
having a script you're running around
town with trying to raise 10 15 20
million dollars on
and not getting it done does not get
anything done
but if you're able to get
similar content or even that that
passion project to yours done for the
money that you really can get or or
raise
and you get it done it's just going to
build and build and build to get to
where you ultimately want to go and
personally i'd rather have four or five
films under my belt in five years than
talking about making one that's just me
personally
you know just that's my advice to
filmmakers is really think about what
you can do something for and where is
this budget coming from because if the
content is good and the cast is
respectable enough to get eyeballs
you're you're going to have you know
hopefully some success with it you're
going to move it
and just because the budget's high does
not guarantee success it doesn't
guarantee distribution there's a lot of
very expensive movies that are sitting
in cans right now that have been done
for years with a-list stars that have
never seen the light of day
you know
and then
you know go make content that's what
it's about
would you say you're asking for less
money these days when you approach an
investor absolutely i mean you know
the the go-to for everybody i think that
is pitching an investor
is well there's so much
so much opportunity for for distribution
now well there might be but what does it
pay
you know the home video market is done
that was really the biggest revenue that
we were seeing on our independent films
when when blockbuster and hollywood
video was out and before the netflix
world
the money that us indie folks saw was
was pretty substantial on the returns
that's not happening anymore so you're
streaming you're seeing sometimes
pennies pennies for streams
and aod and vods where before you were
seeing dollars
so
what we try to do is we we've got it
figured out how to make films on a dime
and make them at least the production
value is good
so what we do is we present a product
that is
marketable it looks good it fits with
everything else that's happening that we
were able to produce for a fraction of
the cost of what everybody else is
making it for which
when it sells the deals are smaller but
the investors are still happy because
the risk was low the rewards are what
they are but it all it all comes
parallel what's happened is
the budgets you know for the films that
we do at like 500 650 000
when home video was around that was gold
but because everything's streaming now
for the most part you may get a few tv
deals that pay okay but you don't want
to count on those those are those are
like you know easter eggs are great when
you find them
but you want to keep your investors
happy you know money out money in and
the returns on those are not only lower
they also take forever to pay these
streaming deals you know when you work
with a distributor they usually have 90
days after the previous quarter to pay
well they're still dealing with the same
thing at their end from the streaming
platforms so the streaming platforms
could take 90 to 120 days to report and
pay them and then they have another 90
days after the quarter to pay you
so you could be looking at eight nine
months before you see a dime on a stream
so these are things that you have to be
very upfront about with your investors
you have to let them know that this is
this is the way it is now
um you know the misnomer is that there's
so many you know big dollar deals for
everybody you hear and read about the
big dollar deals that's that's what
keeps the wheels turning but the
majority
is you're dealing with smaller deals and
i really encourage filmmakers to try to
keep their their budgets
lower so they can get more content made
you can really learn how this industry
is working if you're not working at the
studio system
what would you say is the sweet spot
that an independent filmmaker should
spend on their movie i think a sweet
spot for an independent filmmaker is
it's different for everybody because
content different content drives more
dollars internationally you know comedy
if it's circumstantial comedy that's one
thing but if it's it's written comedy it
doesn't always translate foreign so
you're limiting your foreign
certain films don't do well overseas so
i don't think there's a sweet spot for
everybody i think there are sweet spots
that people can do
and if you're going to spend more money
just put it in the cast it really is
it's if there's content there's content
that fits a niche or a genre but then
there's also star power and if you're
trying to get a-list actors they're
always going to cost you a lot of money
so you know some independent filmmakers
do very well they'll make three or four
million dollar films they'll put two
million dollars into two actors and then
everything else is you know the rest of
the film there's nothing wrong with that
um
if you're doing you know the walk and
talk dramas i you know unless you're
you're knocking it out of the park with
star power why do these films need to be
made for more than three hundred
thousand dollars i just i don't know why
they would need to be if you're not if
you were not justifying it with the star
power
again
spend 10 million if you're getting
george clooney and meg ryan or whoever's
hot today you know it changes every
other day
that's justifiable globally that's going
to do a lot for your revenue
but if you're working with
actors that are really good at their
craft that that are blue collar actors
that are going to get the job done but
they're not marquee
you know you really got to think about
how you can keep the costs down because
again the less you spend the less you're
going to make especially when it comes
to talent
but
again you have to navigate what it is
you're selling if you're selling action
you know what are the star power that
you need to pull the action film or is
it going to do good globally besides
here in north america
horror does that translate worldwide
does you know
psychological thrillers do well you know
every film genre has its goods and bads
all over the globe and you really need
to research that before you find your
sweet spot and we find our sweet spot
just by trial and error i mean you know
we haven't we haven't hit home runs
every time we make a movie you know base
hits and doubles are wonderful but you
really you really need to understand the
playing field before you find your sweet
spot you know and i think it's different
for every every genre and it's different
for every filmmaker too
if a filmmaker is going to raise money
then we should just probably pick some
ballpark figure so maybe 500 000
okay
how can a filmmaker mitigate risk i
think when when putting together
you know a half a million dollar budget
the best way to mitigate risk on that is
to think about genre think about star
power
you know as i as i try to tell a lot of
producers you know
if you
if you're only thinking about what the
public perception is of your work and
the stars that you are working with is
your end game
you're not never going to be happy
you know
be smart in your casting you know just
because
somebody is not a-list studio powerhouse
player today doesn't mean they weren't
5-10 years ago doesn't mean somebody
isn't on three television series that
are syndicating around the globe you
know two or three times a day in 140
different countries those actors are
gold and they're not expensive so you
know when when we when we cast our films
it's about familiar faces it's about
people with good reputation people that
we enjoy being with 18 hours a day
anyway right but i think for mitigating
risk it's about it's about getting
actors that people recognize
and people can say oh i remember this
actor from that series or this series or
that show or that film
and you know
it's when you're working in a half a
million dollars it's really not a lot of
money it goes fast
and you know to be able to put
you know maybe 35 40 of that above the
line i think is is smart and then you
know you you got your your crew and all
below the line you know make sure that's
an efficient team that makes your
product look and sound good
get good editors
do whatever you have to do to make the
product look as good as it can i mean
you can make that that money go a long
way if you know how to do it
but
again it comes down to content a five
hundred thousand dollar drama
without the right cast is not the same
thing as a 300 000 action film with just
one or two right people in it i mean
there they can be completely different
success
so
i always think you know it goes back to
really understanding globally what your
product
how how products of that budget and that
level and similar cast do it's really
important to look at like films i mean
us as filmmakers again it goes back to
thinking everything we do is so special
we're going to knock the world on its
ass because this is just the best script
ever and it's going to be the best movie
ever
i always say you know always go in under
promise over deliver you know and i
think that's the biggest problem with
you know a lot of the pitch decks that
we look at that come through
everybody's got names and faces on these
things they're never going to acquire
and they comp it to films they're not
even ever going to come close to comping
with they always pick the big grand slam
films
and and what i try to teach producers is
that when you go in with all these
promises and hype
you're going to start casting your film
and you're going to have two strikes
against you when your your investor says
well who's in it and you didn't get
the names of the faces that were in your
pitch deck
and you know i think that a lot of
people go in such high expectations and
they get reality check sure you're going
to get the occasional like wow i can't
believe we got this person or that
person
but you know
when when you're pitching to investors i
always say let's just remember the
investors are smarter than we are we're
going to them for money because they are
successful at doing things and it's very
similar to real estate if somebody came
to you
and said i want you to put 500 grand
into this housing project and within 16
months you're going to make 20 million
dollars you probably wouldn't invest
especially it wasn't an accredited
builder developer or somebody that you
know and see the track record that okay
their half million dollars turns into 20
million within a year and a half and a
lot of filmmakers go in with that kind
of pomp and circumstance what i like to
do when i pitch investors is i i use
films that most people haven't heard of
is comps where i say hey this film was
made for 500 grand it made back 3
million
this film was made for 600 grand it made
back seven million because i'm not going
to compare it to blair witch i'm not
going to compare it to napoleon dynamite
those are sh th that stuff's all
lightning in a bottle and and good on
them there's nothing no ding against
them it's just that's reality and
investors sniff that bs a mile away i
think the most important thing when
you're pitching people for money is is
you go and you make the film as low as
you can because the first thing an
investor always wants to know is how
much money are you getting paid you know
we talked about that in some of our
earlier interviews i think how much do
you pay yourself or what shouldn't it
what should you be paid
and you know the old saying is the the
producer is always the first one to buy
lunch and the last to get paid right
i think investors like to see you're not
lining your pockets
they want to know you have certain skin
in the game and when you go to them and
you say look your 500 000 investment if
we place it here here and here with this
star power could generate two to five
million dollars over the next three to
five years
all of a sudden they don't feel they're
getting a snow job and that's that's the
reality of our business and that's if
you're doing well so
i think what's really important is it's
you know you ask about finding the sweet
spot on budget i think it's about
i think you always have to put your
investor first because a lot of people
just want to get one movie made and they
figure they're going to move on to the
next and where we've been very
successful is having a track record with
with investors you know we don't do
one-off investors we work with the same
people over and over again and that
comes from trust it comes from
delivering it comes from putting a
product on the screen that they can be
proud of when it's done
and and having success globally and it
takes time it nothing happens like that
you know and and that's i think the
problem is is all these pitch decks that
come in
are just lined with bs and fluff and
hype
and i think if people just take a step
back and kind of do a reality check and
what they're presenting i think they'd
be a lot more successful in getting
funds it's just about honesty and
integrity
and you said also not just the images
and and in the pitch decks but also
shooting something like a scene that
goes so much further than i i i look at
some of these pocs that people shoot and
they just look they look so good i i've
never been impressed with the pitch deck
and it's just littered it's littered
with [ __ ] i i just got sent a
60-page pitch deck
that i i'm consulting a producer on next
week he sent it to me
i shot holes in 95 of it and they spent
a lot of money getting this pitch deck
made it is useless and it's really
unfortunate because i see it all the
time and it's it's not that i have all
the answers
i've raised a lot of money from private
equity that's what i do i know when they
know they're getting bs and i know what
not to do and these pitch decks are just
constantly just
just filled with so much information
it's paperweight that they don't need
you know less i'm a big i'm a big
proponent of less is more in the room
i talk about it in the book uh the first
time i ever raised private equity i went
into a very successful businessman's
office got took three months to get the
meeting i brought in a briefcase filled
with scripts budgets you know we didn't
have the term pitch deck back then but
head shots and you know what we're going
to do and all the projections and the
ask and takes from the distributors and
all the people that wanted to sign on
and i literally i literally broke out
this this kinkos box if you guys
remember what that is kinko's you know i
think it's fedex printers now i broke
out a box and a guy said stop
what are you giving me i said oh i have
a script i have a budget he said look
around my office and cornered a corner
of his grand office there was stacks of
paper
knee to hip high all over the place
there's just paper and he said these are
all proposals from people that want
money from me he said you want to end up
in the pile give me your paperwork
why don't we just sit here and have a
conversation you tell me what it is you
want to do how much money you need how
long is it going to take for me to start
seeing a return what are you going to do
with it
and we were able to have a conversation
bang bang bang
and that's that's how our our funding
comes it's not with pitch decks it's not
with
reels it's not with anything other than
just eye contact and honesty and
integrity
most of our outlines when we when we
meet with investors is three to five
pages tops they're really small and it's
just it's just facts here you go
so then where where is the idea of these
elaborate pitch decks come from oh i
think it's brand i think somebody came
up with the idea that they make a lot of
money getting them from filmmakers to
build a pitch deck i don't know
and and i'm sure they work i know there
are platforms that do seminars on pitch
decks and i'm sure they work for people
i'm not saying they don't work for
everybody
i just know that i see my share of them
because a lot of people send them in and
say hey will you give me your thoughts
on this pitch deck and they are just
loaded with [ __ ]
and i i really believe less is more it's
you know two plus two's gotta equal four
in an investor's mind a lot of people
that you go to for money have been
pitched everything you know and they
they pay business managers and
accountants a lot of money to protect
them and they're all told the same thing
don't invest in the music industry the
film industry nightclubs or restaurants
right that's like the first thing when
you get money you're told what not to do
so you already go in with a strike
against you when you meet with an
investor
and they've seen it all they've heard it
all and they know
that they have the ability to make your
dreams come true by just saying the
three-letter word yes
and i think speaking too much in the
room is wrong i think
you know even a fool is considered wise
when they're quiet
wait for questions to be asked stay on
point um don't over analyze everything
i've seen more deals get killed in a
room because a potential investor will
ask a question and there's a 30 minute
answer i know i'm long-winded that's my
nature but in the room it's a whole
different ball game yes no
if they ask for something you tell them
how it's going to be and you shut your
mouth
and
you know people ruin their own deals
time and time again with too much
information
and you know as i talk about in the book
don't be afraid to say i don't know one
of the greatest most fruitful
relationships i ever had with a with an
investor came from saying i don't know
he asked me a question i didn't know the
answer and i said sir i don't know but
i'll find out for you
and what that did is allowed me an
excuse to contact them again in a day or
two with the answer to the question they
wanted to know and i called him back i
got him through their secretary he got
on the phone he said yeah what do you
want and i said look really enjoyed our
time together a couple days ago you
asked me a question i didn't have the
answer and he said i did i said yeah i
told him this was your question this is
the answer he said i got to tell you
something after you left my attorney and
i
we enjoyed our meeting with you we made
fun of you in some respect but at your
expense you know that happens we make
fun of everybody who comes in and tap
dances for money
he said but we we were really moved by
the fact that you said you didn't know
the answer to something because it
showed us that you're willing to say you
don't know you were willing to be honest
enough not to bs your way out of it and
you took the time to find out he said
well listen i appreciate the information
i'm going to let you know right now i'm
just going to say yes to your proposal
let's move forward and do it
that that wound up being like a
a financial relationship that went on
for for i don't know how many films and
how many years
and that's that was birthed out of just
saying i don't know
so
you know when it comes to trying to
raise private equity
it's important to remember these people
are smarter than you and they've heard
it all and and i they they can usually
smell right through the bs
you know
cut to the chase with them
they know why you're there
but when they said they made fun of you
did they tell you what some of the
things were like oh eventually they did
you know well you know you get nervous
you know when you're you're tap dancing
for for your next meal you know you
sometimes you tremble sometimes you say
things wrong i think i spilled water on
their coffee table not anything but they
gave me a glass of water and i think i
was reaching for something and i i
spilled and it was you know i was
nervous it's like my first it was my
first attempt at getting capital i was
scared
it seems forgivable but yeah okay yeah
but it was funny to them
i guess so let's see the indie guy
squirmed yeah oh my god and you know
what's funny is
you know what happens i'll tell you i'll
tell you something we talk about money
i've had investors call back
when you know they don't always say yes
and it's
why do you need so much money you know
people are making movies on a dime now
it seems it doesn't seem like you're
blowing stuff up you're not you know
hanging off the empire state building
why do you need so much money investors
are getting more and more savvy about
what things really cost
they become very wise to it there's just
so much information at their fingertips
now the people that they surround
themselves with they they are paid to
investigate and know what things really
cost you know the days of going into
people and asking for millions of
dollars or getting further and further i
mean there are those rare exceptions but
i think you also have to be really savvy
on on an investor's ability
you know keep in mind what you know just
because somebody's rich doesn't mean
they can just roll over and write you
millions of dollars in checks you know
you don't know what their overhead is
that their exposure is what other
responsibilities they have what tax
needs they have or have to avoid
so you know i think it's it's really
important to
if somebody is is introducing you to
somebody that is a potential investor
you need to do your research if somebody
is saying i want to i want to introduce
you to somebody they could be a
potential investor take the time to say
what do they do
what is their family size what are they
you know they got houses all over the
world are they they live a modest
lifestyle are they flashy find out
research them you know google's a
wonderful thing find out some of the
things that have happened in their life
their successes and their failures make
sure they haven't had family tragedies
that is your project may remind them of
and i'm a firm believer whenever you go
into the room to pitch somebody whether
it's an independent financier or it's a
studio always have two or three projects
under your belt or under your your arm
because you may say something and start
down the road of a project and they can
say yeah no no no we're not interested
we don't want to make film like that or
we're not interested we developed
something like that it didn't work
you know you wait two or three months to
get a meeting with somebody and they
tell you in the first two sentences of
your pitch this isn't going to work for
them that meeting is either over or you
can say okay respectfully understood put
it away pull out another project
so if they're accountants let's suppose
these are not
quote unquote film people these usually
are okay so so they're people that have
made money in other
industries and their accountants or
business managers to tell them stay away
from the following things which include
making a film
why do you think they would even say yes
um
well i think there are people that
haven't been told that or if they have
um
they're still open to it you know
i i will be
i i would say that most of the people
that i have been fortunate enough to do
business with have said to me early in a
relationship don't ever ask me to fund a
film i would never do that
and you know you look at it you say well
okay but people who are doing films are
doing very well if they're if they're
done properly and the model is done and
the budget's safe and the output
justifies the investment and there's
also so many incentives to investors
that they're not even aware of whether
it's the write-offs that they can get
and again i always say talk to your
accountant every situation is different
everybody's tax situation is different
every state has different laws and you
know there's different things that need
to be considered but
there have been bills put into place you
know like the jobs act that'll and bless
an investor for investing in a film
there are also investors that have
companies that if you can justifiably
involve that company that they own in
the advertisement aspect that they can
actually get
that film's investment written off as an
advertisement expense and it can do that
you know long-term depreciation
i've even had investors say to me you
know don't don't pay us any money back
right now we're taking a hit on this for
a while for the company
you got to slow the roll on some of
these returns i mean that does happen
everybody's situation is different
but
there's the reality of you know when
people make big money and a lot of
things are
accessible on what people make or how
successful they are i always say cut
those numbers in half they're all you
know fabricated or they're pre-tax
dollars and people have you know people
at that level are pretty responsible
usually
especially if they've been around a long
time and they come from older money that
they didn't just make it yesterday
by picking magic six numbers um
you know you really have to go in and
just because somebody's worth a hundred
million dollars it doesn't mean you ask
for 10 or it doesn't mean you ask for
one you know why don't you start small
and gain their trust have a base hit or
a double
and then they can go back and say what
else do you want to do and so we'll have
this other project we'd like to do the
budget's a little higher than last time
and if you've had success you're not
going to have an issue with it
i've learned some from some people that
are very close to me that have had a lot
of success that they're successful
because of what they say yes and no to
you know smart people in development or
in real estate
they'll make they'll make a move on a
piece of property
and they look at it and say can i make
3x on this in 24 to 32 months
and if the answer is no they don't buy
the property so as a filmmaker you can't
guarantee that
so what is your pitch going to be what
is your angle going to be and that's how
a lot of savvy investors think
and then it goes back to the bs and the
fluff on a pitch deck trying to appeal
to that mindset and you know nine times
out of nine you're not going to fulfill
those promises so you have to be very
careful in your presentation you know
some of our investors said look
i know you don't want to hear this
you come off a 30 million dollar studio
film you you can do something with a
hundred grand show what you can do with
a hundred grand
that makes sense
we'll move on we'll get bigger and
bigger sometimes you gotta come back and
say look with that hundred grand you're
not gonna have the success you're gonna
hope to see because with that money
you're offering we can't get the star
that's gonna move this over the hump
so can you come up to 150 give me
another 50 grand so i can get this actor
or that actor and i'll show you what i
can do for the 100 plus the talent side
and then we can have a conversation and
often they'll say oh okay i understand
how that works now and they'll start
working with you on that
you got to be open and fluid and those
doors should never be closed i've had
everybody who's ever invested in me has
told me no
everybody i nobody has rolled over and
said absolutely let's do it it's it's
always come from people who have said no
right as the first absolutely even even
the gentleman who financed my first film
wasn't the first time i've come to him
for money
yeah it took five years to get them to
do it
so it did yeah it's always been those
everybody i've everybody i've been
blessed enough to be backed by has
started with with seasons of no's or
just don't don't come to me for film i
don't want to do it
what kind of money are distributors
paying for movies today
you know
it depends i mean you could get you can
get a good distributor to come in and
it's all about territories how much term
uh how long is the contract going to be
you know making deals with certain
platforms or certain distributors looks
really good
on social media and cocktail parties but
some of those deals can go 25 30 years
now and they pay you know
a couple hundred grand maybe maybe more
but
what are they owning and for how long
and what does that limit your other
sales potential
you know i'm a big fan of trying to sell
films territory by territory there are
times where you get opportunities to
sell them in a block where somebody will
come along and say we want to own 10 11
territories and here's what we're
willing to pay
sometimes it's good sometimes it's not i
think you have to look at both sides of
it you have to look at the long term or
how long are they going to have it you
know sometimes these
these awful financial offers come with
30 years on the other side where you
know i'm 50. i don't i don't need to be
80 to get the rights back
you know so sometimes the lesser money
per territory if it's shorter term three
to five years you know could be more
attractive every deal is different
you know you may get
every territory spending between 10 and
forty thousand dollars but there's you
know ultimately fifty plus territories
to sell around the globe they take time
um a lot of them don't pay up front
a lot of them don't pay until they have
it delivered and it's past qc so you
know just because you make a deal you
may not see the money for six months
people forget that um so that's again
why you know when you're an independent
filmmaker i think you have to look at
the the real picture it doesn't mean
you're not going to have something that
just surprises the world and you just
make a huge deal that that does happen
but it doesn't happen to everybody so
you know to be a blue collar filmmaker
and to be able to continue to do what
you do you have to to keep that in mind
i think you have to you realize that the
average deal is going to probably be
five to seven years that a territory is
going to come in
um are they going to pay 50 upon
execution of the deal are they going to
pay 50 upon delivery that's that's an
attractive way to go where they're going
to put up 50 upon signing
and then you know when you get to your
sales agent you're going to have a
quality you know qc version master that
they'll be able to deliver and all that
went through so you're not doing a
territory for territory once you have
that qc that's passed that show that's
past muster everybody's going gonna get
that when they get it
but i no two deals are the same you know
you can have one film
where all of a sudden you know the uk or
germany is paying
45 50 grand
and then china is going to pay 10 or 15
and then you can have another film where
china's paying 35 40
and then you know the uk is paying 10 or
15. i mean it's it's never consistent
again it goes back to genre big genre
also cast does it fit what they're
looking to do
um
but you know again
as i talk about in the book there's
there's 54 territories on the globe 172
buying countries right so
you have to realize that some of those
territories are going to pay crap
they're going to pay five seven ten
grand but you do have some that are
going to pay very well
and you you have to break that down when
again when you budget a film always
think with the end in mind
if i make this film and it's this genre
and this is the cast i'm realistically
going to get
globally what is that actor or these few
actors do in a film of this nature or of
this genre and really break it down
don't look at ask and take sheets that
every sales agent is going to give you
that tells you they're going to ask for
150 grand in germany and accept 75 grand
that's never going to happen that's
those are just numbers that they just
provide these ask and take sheets
they're the same ones it doesn't matter
whose names on them they all look alike
don't go by that
and sales agents will provide that for
you to get your business it's called an
ask take sheet
and it's um you know it's very rare
those numbers even come close
define a walk and talk
a walk and talk drama
uh you know i i don't even know if it's
a real term i've i've heard it used by
sales agents and distributors talking
about you know films that
you can look at something like harry met
sally could be considered like you know
a walk and talk romantic comedy it's
it's not an action film it's not set in
outer space or with green screens it's
it's practical
um i think like you've got males a great
example of a walk and talk you know it's
it still has the romantic comedy
elements
um when we did mistrust with jane
seymour that was that was that's a walk
and talk drama okay that's the first
time i've ever heard the term and i
started hearing it more and more i think
i think terms come and go
you know but that's that's my
understanding of what it is i'm probably
wrong i'm sure your viewers will tell me
how wrong i am but that's that's what i
understand it to be
and are those the hardest to sell
they can be tough
depending on the cast
so if if you're not selling action
you're not selling suspense
you know something that's getting the
heart going
and it's it's a drama you know i you
really need to push the cast
um
you know because you're asking people to
you know you think about you think about
the independent films that have done
well and who's cast in them and what
they are and
um you know whenever whenever we're
teeing up to do a drama and we don't
really do those much anymore but when
you tee out for him it's about cast it's
really just about cast
you know that's important we do an
action film it's more about okay we've
got an action film coming let's think
about some of these actors who are going
to do well globally in different
territories and why
you know and action cells
suspense you know thrillers those things
do well
you know everybody they translate into
every language
and something else to keep in mind sorry
i'll no no go ahead you know they
translate and they translate in
different languages but something also
think about is when when you do drama
you know it's something i i talk to
people a lot about especially now coming
out of where we've been for the last
year and a half do we do we really want
to deal with too much drama anymore i
mean i don't know and and the question
is is does the world want what we
consider drama do they want our drama do
they want our
problems you know drama comes with a lot
of
emotion it comes with a lot of feelings
it comes with a lot of baggage it
doesn't it doesn't mean it's bad it's
you know it's what makes some of the
great dramas but
i always i always try to to to remind
people think about what we're coming out
of people have been living in their
you know their homes or their their
dwellings for a year and change and they
haven't been able to socialize much they
haven't gone on vacation take them
places they want to go let them
experience exciting things
you know that never gets old people want
to see beautiful things and get excited
and i think you can incorporate that in
drama but don't forget you know
always think about where the world is
right now
and
what if you were totally detached from
this film completely detach yourself
from it think about the year you've just
had do you want to sit and watch
somebody else go through some drama
right now
totally for the drama genre i love it
but i just think you have to be
sensitive to the global climate when
you're making certain product
but the queen's gambit worked that was
going to work that was just awesome
would you say that was some action or no
not not really
but it had sensuality it had it had some
eroticism to it it had
mystique it had
edgier seat moments because of some of
the things that she went through you
know with her addictions and dealing
with her family drama and and her
background i mean i think if i remember
correctly i saw it you know not a long
time ago now but i think she was a was
she adopted or
something she was in an orphanage
orphanage yeah yeah i mean there's
there's a lot of baggage there but they
were able to educate an audience and you
know what i thought the coolest thing
was and nobody was surprised is when
they talked about the number of chess
chess games that sold after the success
of that film and they couldn't keep
chess in stock you know this became the
hottest thing in the world everybody's
buying chess
and i i always so obviously they did
something besides being just such a
brilliant execution of such a great show
is it it got people excited about a new
hobby and and that's a cool thing too
you know
and we could root for the underdog even
though she was kind of three steps ahead
of most of the people oh she was but she
was but in watching the chess games and
and the looks on the little the little
tells and the micro expressions and
things and and wondering was this going
to be the one that was going to take her
down yeah you know that's right and all
of the
um you see popping circumstance that was
around certain the the notorious players
and then sure this
she's going to come in you know so
it was great i liked i liked the janitor
that taught her how to play
benny
he needs a spin-off he sure does yeah
yeah
yeah i wasn't sure where we were going
with him at first i wasn't either i was
like ah it's a little creepy and then i
realized oh okay okay he's a good guy i
know exactly but yeah it had that
intrigue but no i think there's nothing
wrong with drama but i think during the
drama you have to have those those
moments to breathe and and experience
new things you know as a filmmaker we've
talked about it before filmmaker's job
is to bring an audience to some place
they've never been never knew existed
who's always afraid to have gone to
or always you know wanted to go
and i think in drama you can still do
that even with some of the experiences
or adventure that maybe a romance let's
say it's a
a romantic it's not a comedy but it's a
romantic drama you know there's drama
and you know maybe somebody's a widow or
somebody is cheating on a spouse and
they're going through this journey of a
new relationship and that's that's when
things almond king did very well if you
watched like nine and a half weeks what
made that in its time
was
was what that relationship did between
the incredible
sex scenes
the thrill and the exuberation of that
relationship and where it took its
viewers and it's time and i think that's
important to do
sure and there was romance in the
queen's gambit there was that's right
that's right
but there was also excitement and the
way uh and then i'll just close it there
but just that a lot of the shots were
i'm not sure what the exact terminology
is but there are like these upshots of
of them following her upstairs and
getting like this wide view of her sort
of walking into a room and but but also
in your right and what was really cool
about it is they took us places we've
never been and her journey when she
became a professional chess player the
places around the world she went and
some of these incredible rooms and these
halls and these hotels and
we got to experience that especially
during covid when we were all stuck at
home is when most of us saw that you
know and even shit's creek you talk
about a show that exploded during the
pandemic i mean everybody was talking
about that show early on in the pandemic
and and you know here was just this
great concept of this this very wealthy
family that everything stripped from
them that had to go to this small town
but
what what fun and that's circumstantial
comedy that i think translates a lot
better than slapstick comedy because
people can get that from all walks of
life every language that'll translate
you know so i think you just have to be
smart in picking your content just you
have to again we talk about how us
artists are so myopic and selfish we
just have to take a step back and say
okay if you were detached from this
realistically how do you think this
would be accepted take your passion take
your investment of your time or your
your your talent away from this for just
five minutes really think about how this
would do on a global scale and why
how much money can filmmakers expect to
make from streaming services today
don't expect anything i i think every
deal is different every situation is
different um there are there are some
really cool
streaming services or platforms that are
popping up all the time that you know
tubi's a new one
um obviously you've got your netflix
your amazon your hulu
you know
i think i think netflix you know if you
make a deal with them they acquire the
project i think i think people will be
surprised for what they actually acquire
independent films for and people need to
realize they pay that over i think two
years it's not just one big check
um and that's fine that's that's what
they do
um
you know there are some some aod
platforms that are that are doing
surprisingly well i never say what
anybody should expect
i i work with sales agents and
distributors all the time that are
working with films that have been dead
catalogued collect dust in a closet
haven't seen a light a day in 15 20
years they're throwing them on some of
these aod platforms and they're bringing
in 5 to 20 grand a month just on like
dead titles
it and then you have stuff that costs a
lot more that are recent and slick and
they're not making a dime there's i
don't think there's
there's really a
guarantee for anything um
i you know i think that
um there are some really good streaming
platforms out there there's some you
know obviously the the more the merrier
if you can get different territories
different platforms you know they have
some platforms now that'll get your your
work out on you know you can make deals
with some distributors they'll get your
get your work out on 32 different
platforms you know every major cable
outlet
including xbox and playstation i mean
those are some really attractive things
but how well do they pay
um
you know i i don't want to give you a
number and say this is what you can
expect because it what you know we
always have to remember about this
business
is to hope for the best prepare for the
worst and expect the unexpected and it
goes back to learning something new
every day you know
there are some streaming platforms that
i've heard or just
oh my god you got to get with them
and
you see what the deal is and you just
say that's the last thing i want to do
and then there are some platforms that
you've never heard of that you just say
i i wouldn't be caught dead being
affiliated with this and then they say
well sit down here's what our mg is
we're going to give you a minimum
guarantee for one year and then after
the second year you have first right of
refusal if you're happy with that we're
going to pay you you know 40 afterward
you sit there and you go so wait you're
going to give an mg on a streaming deal
for that much money
huh okay and these things i mean i get
hit with these things every other day
where
there's the misconception of some of the
bigger ones
and then there's this i've never heard
of you before but you're willing to
guarantee it
i wish i had the answer for you but i i
think it's one of those things that
every film
every film with a cast from every
filmmaker is going to be treated
differently in that i just do i just do
i don't think there is a tried and true
number yet
there's too many new platforms popping
up
they're everywhere
from our previous interview shane we had
one video that had a lot of comments
that we were hoping to run by you and
maybe get some clarification on the big
reason why many people will never have a
career in the film industry
and so here's one comment sounds great
in theory but we literally can't afford
to spend our time not getting paid these
days honestly lol
i could
read another if you'd like okay okay
you can hustle be the quote johnny on
the spot and still fall through the
cracks starting out i worked on a ton of
projects for free as much as i could
living at home and later when i saved up
and moved to la but eventually those
resources run out and you have to pay
rent there's a definite class element to
being able to go out and spend two years
working for free
nobody should work for free here's
another one quick question if you work
on a movie 12 plus hours a day for a
month and you do that for a year or so
for free dot dot dot how exactly do you
pay rent question mark
okay here's another one
i've been working my tail
on
i'm gonna probably tail off that's just
thinking about working the tail off
working their tail yeah
wax on wax off sorry okay um i've been
working my tail off on crappy jobs
outside the movie industry and i cannot
accept unpaid jobs inside the industry
because i have to eat and live and that
costs money i am a little confused about
this attitude of stanley thanks that you
are supporting such a bad role model i'm
a bad role model okay god i feel bad
that so much of this was misconstrued
and i don't blame the the the viewers
and and i'd first like to apologize if
anything was misunderstood i am not
telling you to sell your soul work for
free live on the streets and not pay
rent
um let me clarify a few things with that
because i encourage you to get out there
and work and hustle and do what you have
to do to get on a set a lot of the sets
that you're going to get on cannot
afford you anyway
and they or they are already filled and
what my point was it doesn't mean you go
work 75 hours a week for free six days a
week on a film
it means you make yourself available to
a producer or a filmmaker and say look i
have a job i need to get time on a set
can i put in two days a week i'm off
saturday and tuesdays i'm off the
weekend i'm off at night and get
yourself involved and in the loop of
people that are doing what you
ultimately want to do i'm not saying
that you've got to go you know live in
your car to go work for free i
personally worked for free a lot but i
also had other jobs just because i had a
father in the industry trust me it
didn't help me
in a way that a lot of people think it
might have when i when i decided that i
wanted to make a living in film the only
thing my father gave me was his rolodex
he said great
there you go you know some of the people
in there make some calls
i worked for hundreds of different
people before he hired me full-time i
wasn't until my mid-20s until i was
working with my dad full-time we had a
lot of success early on with his
documentaries and shows that he did we
did one every two years
i moved out when i was 18. i didn't have
my rent covered i was out hustling i
held odd jobs i sold cars i worked at
restaurants i waited tables i bus tables
you know i detailed cars i mowed lawns i
painted houses i did construction
i still found a way to get on a set
every week and put in my time to make
new contacts so
what i'm trying to encourage you guys to
understand is it's not going to come to
you
you have to make sacrifices i am not
asking you to [ __ ] yourself out and
work for free for everybody all the time
to start to get a track record as a
reliable resource on a set it's like
interning you know we have a lot of
interns that come and go on our shows
from films from film school that work on
our productions we we get them when we
can they get credit some of our greatest
regular
crew members that we pay are from
interns from college that came in and
worked for two or three days a week if
we were lucky during a production from
four years ago
it's just to encourage everybody to
understand it's not coming to you
if it's not coming to you how are you
going to get something you know if you
want to get to an island it ain't coming
to you you either swim or take a boat
if you don't have money for a boat you
don't have the resources for a boat get
in the water start swimming that's all
i'm trying to say it's to encourage you
guys to understand that's what i had to
do i brought up a friend of mine whose
father had two oscars his mother had i
think five or seven emmys
when he pulled his head out of his ass
and decided he wanted to work in the
film industry he told his parents his
plan assuming they would get him work
they said great dad picked up the phone
and i think he called deluxe which was
an old film color house back in the day
my friend was sweeping floors there for
two years before they let him sit behind
an edit bay
that was the job he got the first year
he was there he was there two or three
hours a day and he wasn't paid that's
just how it was back in our day if i
offend people of today's generation
because we actually worked for free and
earned our stripes by busting ass and
bringing our own lunch sorry you were
offended but that's how we did it
we still have people that want to intern
that show up we still have great people
that come in and say look i'd like to
give you a day on the set i want to show
you what i'm about because we're not
looking for the help we have the people
that are on the team so it's about
people coming to us and saying i want to
show you what i can do for you of course
we're going to feed you we'll water you
come on out for a few hours show us what
you got so when we make our next film we
know to call you and there's a lot of
filmmakers that are willing to do that i
used to call everybody i knew in that
rolodex and i called them and we didn't
have text and email it was phone calls
and it was you know hey phil hearn it's
shane stanley lee's son
yeah that one um listen i need to get on
a set do you need somebody to be a pa in
ac a second you know what can i do to
get on a set phil would call back
sometimes and say yeah if you want to
come work on saturday we're doing a show
with richard krenna come on out bring
your own lunch i'll i'll get you on the
set giant getting paid and i'd show up
you know i did that with steve elkins
phil hearn did that with uh ken shafer i
did that with with tom coster i did that
with with you know chad shoe cat i think
got me on a couple of shows it's just
what we did and i i hope and i
understand times have changed and all
that but my my
heart and my spirit of telling you what
i did last time that ruffled some
feathers
was not sell your soul and work for free
for 70 hours a week do your
meet your responsibilities with your
paying job but we all don't work 70
hours a week for a paying job so you
find the time to get on a set even if
it's three hours a day and show people
what you got and be around people that
are doing what you love so they know
that they can call and rely on you that
was the sole purpose of that
why do you think um
younger generations have reacted
stronger than maybe
you know previous ones it's because a
lot of interns have been taken advantage
of
yeah i think so i mean when you work
with interns you can't you can't replace
interns you can't replace employees with
interns and i think you know ever since
the big black swan lawsuit
that changed the dynamics you know we
work very closely with a lot of amazing
schools you know the laccla
vc uh we're working with college of the
desert this year out in palm springs and
pierce college and you know the rules
are simple is is you know
give the kids the opportunity
let them shadow and and our our guys on
our crew are so amazing with them
because they
they've been fortunate in their
upbringing
and they understand what hard work is
they don't let the kids sit around
they're like hey grab an end of that
come on let me show you how to clean a
lens we had interns literally doing
second ac duties for for a film when we
had a second ad
i'm sorry second ac and and to watch
these kids learn how to pick up these 60
or 70 000 lenses and clean them and prep
them and put them on the cameras they're
not learning that in the classroom and i
guarantee you they're not learning that
during a pandemic so we're really big
about interns coming out and learning
various
jobs on the set you know we try to move
them to sound to camera to a.d upm they
come shadow me for a day they can learn
everything what not to do um you know go
into hair and makeup learn how that is
go learn wardrobe and how we tag
everything for the days and the scenes
and how sometimes wardrobe is used for
half of the day it's put away we use it
for an hour something else and then we
go back to that and just the way the
schedule is how we shoot
they don't learn these things in a
classroom
and um you know
[Music]
they're paying for an education that
that they get in a class and so when
they're able to come on a set with
filmmakers that are willing to open
their doors and their hearts to say come
learn
you know and that's that's what that's
that's the spirit of what i what i try
to
you know
to
encourage
shane we're hoping to get your take on
what might be the problem with hollywood
movies today i i don't know if there's a
w what is the problem i think there's a
lot of disgruntled unemployed people
bitching about what's being made because
they're not working
i mean and that's that's part of why i
did what i did i got tired of not
working so went out and created content
i'm not knocking anybody who's not
working
um
i
i think the big complaint from everybody
is well it's all sql prequel and remake
and it's all you know spandex you know
men in capes and spandex and action hero
movies and
if that's what they're considering the
problem but there's still plenty of
content
um
i i learned from a studio head about
nine years ago when when these superhero
movies were really becoming a thing
and and they told me you ain't seen
nothing yet it's going to get
unbelievable with with different studios
buying you know acquiring different
branches of different comic book
companies whether it's dc or marvel or
different you know one-offs
in in like remaking movies that we've
all heard of and i asked why why do you
do it he said well there's a big
audience for it and i get that
but
they said the the branding's already
there you know when a studio makes a
movie people forget that there's a
tremendous amount of pna that goes into
it you know princeton advertising and
pushing this thing and when you have a
project i mean you can take something
like jungle cruise i mean you've got you
know two of the biggest stars in the
world in it everybody knows what it is
disney's jungle cruise you know i mean
140 000 people go to disneyland every
day when there's no pandemic so
everybody should know that that's built
in branding you know it's it's about for
studios it's it's you talk about
mitigating the risk you talk about
lessening the chances of putting all
this money into television commercials
and billboards that are going to get
covered by another film next week and
pushed aside
and people
people already have a knowledge of you
know what it is because we've seen it as
you know fantasy island adam's new tv
show that's been remade and is now on
fox we all know what fantasy island is
that's built-in branding you know they
did it with dynasty they did it with
dallas
you know they reboot everything now
it
i don't think it's as much about there
aren't any new ideas i think it goes
back to fear i i honestly think it goes
back to fear with decision makers
wanting to make shows that were proven
successful at one time or had built-in
branding that people are going to want
to watch for curiosity factor they're
going to want to watch because they
loved it at one time i'll tell you a
show that would
blow it out right now that would do
really well they would just remake heart
to heart can you imagine that show today
that's a modern day mr mrs smith yeah
you know that show would be a great
remake
um
i i it's just one of those things though
i mean i i think the
the remakes have become a bit much for
me
art's nothing but opinion there is a
hungry audience out there for content
um
i i don't want to say anything's wrong
with hollywood but i think a lot of
of
disgruntled people in town that have
fresh ideas that they believe their
scripts are really
different and good and they probably are
are upset when they see airspace and
screens filled with remakes that were
done 20 30 years ago that's where the
frustration comes from and again i'm not
knocking people that
are
not working i mean again i i got tired
of watching sequels prequels and remakes
get made and finally just said screw it
i'm just going to find a way to make my
own stuff because nobody else wants to
maybe my stuff is that bad but that's
that's why i try to push people to
really find ways to partner with people
that can get their stuff done god forbid
somebody loves your little indie project
and says you should be directing the
next superman i mean it could happen
you know and uh i i
i'm disappointed in hollywood i i think
there's a
safety factor a lazy factor that's come
in i'm not gonna lie i don't disagree
with what you're saying and what people
are saying
but
you know the opportunity to to to get a
studio or a platform such as a netflix
to commit if you have an original series
idea it's gonna cost them between 50 and
150 million dollars for 10 hours of
content that's a big risk
on something that hasn't been proven
when everybody's afraid to make a chance
and you know when you're putting up 200
million dollars to put it on 4 000
screens you're gonna tend to go for the
tried and true and i think that's really
what they've done and it's really hurt
the new writer it's really hurt the
person that has honed their craft and
has written some great specs that are
just not getting looked at because there
isn't a home for it
so my my advice is don't be angry it
hurts me when i see writers who are not
working blasting the things that are
getting made it seems the writers do
that more than anything and and i
understand the frustration i'm not
saying you're wrong to feel that way
but i don't think you're doing anything
good for yourself
by
by blasting what's getting made go make
something better or just go make
something and show the world what you
can do
don't don't talk about it be about it
you know that's that's the advice i give
to people that that have aspirations
again i keep repeating myself it's not
coming to you you have to go on out and
get it and whether that's go work on a
set you know a day or two a week for
free
or it's going out and getting a dslr and
a couple of people from a local acting
class and playing out scenes and really
doing a poc a proof of concept on your
vision of what your script can be
that's how that's how it's going to get
done for you
you know that's that's my advice and
that's my feeling on it i think
hollywood has gotten quite lazy i think
they've gotten complacent i think they
are
content with the numbers that they get
with their
remakes of the same old same old i'm not
i'm not
endorsing it at all that's why i go out
in the dirt and do what i do i i don't
personally like that stuff at all i
understand the anger and the frustration
but
being angry about it and and trying to
get attention online or trying to pull
down other people that are doing stuff
that you're not doing doesn't it doesn't
help anybody just go show them what you
can do sure
i would enjoy seeing a remake of alice
or taxi oh taxi i don't know striking a
car that's one of my favorites i don't
even mean you know
would people would be uber you'd just
call it uber that's true or lyft or yeah
just call it lyft or uber um alice would
be great one of my favorite shows
growing up with linda lavin and uh
victory back and yeah yeah that was a
great show for those of you who don't
know what it is look at some great
television
um all in the family could never be made
again we know that
um but there were some great shows that
they haven't remade
but they they do they do find a way to
keep remaking and rebranding stuff and
that's all about built-in branding
well two broke girls was similar
to alice in some ways but i realized it
was much you know
raunchier and right right you know push
some boundaries it did yeah i don't
think it get made today
oh you don't think so i don't know i
didn't watch the show but i've i've
heard that that
in some of the discussions that i've had
with some of the writers that we do um
on some of the platforms that we
interact with you know aspiring
screenwriters and they want to pitch and
they talk about different things and
somebody was talking about two broke
girls i've never seen an episode of it
and somebody had said do you think that
that would get made today and a lot of
people said no they pushed some
boundaries so
i just that's one that's kind of like
you know we obviously know blazing
saddles is the go-to that would never
get made today
and you know you think about the content
in that film
um
but forgive me two girl girls was like
less than 10 years ago right i think it
was yeah so so we've
we've changed that much where we can't
in that short of time we it would be too
much to push i don't again i haven't
seen it i just found it interesting that
you know it's funny whether it's an
industry conversation or it's just
people
the joke is always like well you know
blazing saddles would never get made
today that's like the go-to for film and
and it was just kind of weird that
everybody was kind of on this two broke
girls bandwagon i could be wrong i've
been wrong you know 100 times today but
i i just found that odd that people
thought so i thought it was a very
successful sitcom that
looked endearing and fun and you know
i'm afraid i'm a fan of whitney i just
never got into the show
but it just seemed to strike a chord
with a few people on these on these
different you know webinars we were
doing and they all seemed kind of like
yeah do you think that would get made
today did they push them maybe it was
racial or sexual boundaries since me too
since some of the other things we've
been through as a society did they push
those envelopes you would know you've
seen it
i haven't seen
that many episodes but i know from the
few that i did yes there was definitely
content
on there i think that's probably what's
not which probably made the show which
probably made the show good you know we
have we have
we went through a time
i'm probably gonna really ruffle some
feathers with this one so let's let's do
it
we went through a time as a society we
got so desensitized
you know when natural-born killers came
out the big fear was oh my god have we
gotten to that point in society
where things are said and done and we
don't even blink at it anymore we don't
care we're okay with that
and then
now we've gotten to a point where we
really
really are trying not to offend certain
people or push boundaries anymore and i
think it's really interesting how
50 when did when did natural born
killers come out you know 25 years ago
how that really turned it into how
desensitized we've become to now how
sensitive we are
think about that i mean it's been a
radical shift
especially in the last four years
well it seems like with cinema and
television but then everyone's okay
pulling out cameras if an incident
happens in real life so it's like
it's okay for us to do that
and share some horrific things that way
and that's acceptable well it's real
life that's what's happening
okay so then we don't want to see it in
the cinema even though this is what's
being apparently known okay but i always
thought or imitated life so
okay you know i'm not disagreeing with
you
i just but i see the difference yeah you
know i knew the gentleman who put the
rodney king beating on the air that was
a much longer tape than we saw as a
public
um i think he acquired the tape for 300
from the gentleman who you know got the
camcorder and was filming outside his
balcony
and um it was very disturbing there was
nothing good about it i'm not making
light of what we didn't see but there
was a lot that wasn't shared with the
public
and that changed everything so it really
when that rodney king incident hit the
airwaves as a society we we woke up to a
whole different animal in our in our you
know the underbelly of what was going on
and
i i it's you know obviously what we went
through
you know with george floyd in the last
year you know and that being caught on
camera
and and it's just it's
you know
you're right i mean
the things that are shown that people
are catching on live camera just there's
no we didn't think twice about it it's
shocking sometimes sure i don't know if
you know again we become desensitized to
a lot of things we see
but
do we want it in the art that we go pay
to see
and is us as storytellers i think there
are some filmmakers and i and i mean
this with
the purest of heart please understand
where this is coming from i think there
are some storytellers that have a a
right
and should be given
the past
to show and exploit certain things in
their art
because i think there's so much that we
see
on a on a camera that's caught in 30
seconds
where so often
when when the right artist tells that
story they get into
the build up they they get into the
aftermath you know we we're so used to
seeing news
like that we'll look at you know
somebody have a fit and a walmart
because they're not wearing a mask we'll
see somebody get choked out by a police
officer
and it just comes at us at the speed of
light and when somebody can take an hour
and a half two hours and really break
down
the psyche and the build up and what
happened and then the aftermath you know
we don't have
when we see something shocking on the
news which is usually what you know news
is now 50 somebody's camera it feels
like
there's never a follow-up it's very rare
you know they may say oh there was there
was sadly there was somebody killed in a
street race they found the guy
but we don't get
the aftermath that's a good point and
that's that's what i don't like about
the news is you know obviously we did
with george floyd and some of the other
situations that are similar that we've
been dealing with as a society because
it's it's warranted that and it's it's
it's attracted that much attention and
rightfully so but we watch stuff all the
time on on social media that we just
went through it and we watch something
crazy it goes on for 20 seconds we whip
through it see something else we never
know the outcome of that we don't know
what caused it and i think there are
some artists that are sensitive
enough they have a sensitivity in the
ability to really tell a story from
beginning to end in aftermath you know
beginning middle end and dominate
of what happened and i think too many of
us storytellers just feel what we're
storytellers we can do it and i i think
i think there's a very very select few
who have the right to do it
would you say that filmmakers today are
more about forcing a message than
telling a good story that's a great
question um
i think i think there's there's quite a
few that do that
um
i think telling a good story is
important whether it's it's you know a
fun
[Music]
you know
romp in the desert or it's a story about
a collapse of
you know the housing industry like you
know the big short i mean wow was that a
message or was that a story yeah i think
it was both
i really do will we learn from it time
will tell
i think set your watch to that but
um
you know i think you know as
storytellers we have a responsibility as
writers we have a responsibility um
a lot of people you know i think i think
well if you look at the faith based
genre it's all about the message they
don't care about story as much as they
do it's the message it's the message
it's the message and
you know
that's cool that's that's their thing
um
[Music]
you know sometimes the story is good i'm
not saying they're not always but
there's there's its message
is the the integrity and the point
behind those
um you know i don't
you know i don't know
what
what different artists intent is i think
some people go in with the intent to
tell a good story and it becomes message
heavy
um and i think the other way around too
sometimes people go on wanting to give a
message and it ends up being a good
story or you know it doesn't
um
i think i think everybody as a
storyteller
has an intention whether they're willing
to show their hand
or
really
you know i think the good storytellers
are able to do both
without people realizing what's
happening i mean i think when you can
seduce an audience and kind of woo them
along and really get them in your story
regardless of what story you're telling
whether it's chariots of fire i mean you
talk about that that was a faith-based
movie
people don't realize that that you know
eric little not not
competing on the lord's day and the
background of his religious background
there was a lot of religious undertones
in that but it was a hell of a story and
it was such a brilliant film
and you know
was it message driven or was it story
driven i think it probably was a good
hand of both
in my opinion anyway
you know looking on golden pond
you know henry fonda and jane fonda i
mean there was a story there but there
was such a message about family and
communication
and and how we drift apart with age and
circumstances but
you know i think there's a way to do
both but
your question was do i think one one
this is people become more focused on
one or the other i think
as we go through what we have in our
times i think i think a lot of people
run to a message as storytellers i think
that's a big thing
i i see a lot of short films and theses
films that are message driven
and they're not thinking about the story
as much but that's that's coming from a
lot of film school students and you know
newbies that
they they want to jump on a cause and
and sometimes just saying there's
anything wrong with that i think you
know
um
i think sometimes when you when you're
dealing with sensitive issues or you're
dealing with
subject matters that we're still really
feeling
you know the aftermath or the aftershock
from um that's a that's a good way to
get some attention as a storyteller to
to let people see what it is that you're
trying to do as an artist and sometimes
you have to
you have to
to pick the scab a little bit
you mentioned that taxi was one of your
favorite shows growing up was there a
message with the tv show
was louis de palma was he
did he have something that he was trying
to tell us and we didn't see it i think
he was just a
i think you know i always thought danny
devito was the youngest
of probably five children
and he probably you know like arthur
spooner and the king of queens never
really was heard growing up
and he was a bully and you know the
funny thing was is he was you know five
foot nothing 100 and nothing and
you know ran the roost it was his show
you know i mean it was his that was his
garage
and there was there was messages but you
know occasionally he would have a life
lesson but before they faded to black
you'd always slide back to old louie
right that's true but but the things
that judd hirsch's character would would
go through with you know tony danza or
elaine or you know
bobby wheeler's character i forget his
name the actor that passed
um
and you know my favorite was jim jim
mcnitowski christopher lloyd's character
i mean that was my favorite character
i watched the show for him as a kid i
thought he was hilarious and latke vodka
was great that's great yeah yeah and
latke's wife yeah yeah i mean was there
a message you know i think you talk
about people coming from all different
backgrounds and all different you know
walks of life and being able to work
together and
encouraging alex was always kind of that
wise owl of the group you know they went
to him for advice or sometimes he got
himself in a pickle and
you know elaine would help him out you
know so i i think it's neat when shows
that we and deer
touch on us without hitting us over the
head and i think taxi was a brilliant
example of of giving us little life
lessons without ever feeling like we
were being preached at
you know i like shows like that don't
hit me over the head you know let me
enjoy the people the circumstances and
go along for the ride and oh you happen
to give me a little life lesson here all
right it was it was extra worth the time
whereas with fantasy island there was
always a message
usually there was wasn't there once you
know when when
mr rorke
was was speaking to tattoo at the end
there there was some kind of a message
that that show was on past my bedtime i
never got through the third act
i don't know if they'll have the same
message in the remake
but looks like they've really rebranded
it i like the fact that they have a
woman now as the
mr roar character i think
it appears that way i haven't seen it
yet but looking at some of the previews
of it i think they have a woman now
leading the charge which i think is
great
um
you know but yeah there were messages i
know there was about people finding love
or i think wasn't it
again forgive me
uh i think it was also a lot of people
fantasies chasing something that they're
never going to get and being able to
accept and love and appreciate what they
truly had as they think what kind of was
the
underlying tone of the show wasn't it
as an audience member or fan do you feel
that movies today are lecturing you more
than they previously did not the stuff
that i watch
i don't i don't allow myself to get into
that i i i'm very you know
time is precious our time on this earth
is limited
you know um
something doesn't doesn't get me early i
just i have an off button like the rest
of the world i just i just don't
go down roads that i just feel if
something's going in a direction that i
don't personally agree with or
it just doesn't hold me i don't wait it
out you know i'd rather go on and do
something else so i can't answer that
um
i just you know
i like shows that allow me to
do the things that i want to do when i
tell a story let people go where they
haven't gone take them someplace they
didn't know existed i let them just
forget about their circumstances and
enjoy something for 90 minutes or
however long it is that they're watching
um
but you know
i i always love it when there's
something
you know there's always that saying when
we work on something we always we always
try to leave the audience with something
you know more than an empty box of
popcorn at the end of a show i think
it's i think i think it's a filmmaker's
responsibility i mean no matter how
ragtag or crazy a show is i think i
think there's always i think show always
needs heart you got to have characters
you care about and can relate to so i
think it's important that you know as
storytellers we allow our audiences to
relate to characters or at least want to
learn more about a character and if we
have some self-discovery during the ride
super that's great
i don't look for films like that or
projects like that
when i watch something
[Music]
but you know i like nice surprises as i
said earlier i think sometimes when you
walk away from something wow you know i
gave me a different point of view or i
never thought of that or
really interesting to see a different
side from you know of society that maybe
i don't come in contact with all the
time and to see their upbringing their
point of view or you know one of the
shows that i'm absolutely
in love with
is um
blanking on the name right now it's um
snowfall
john singleton created that show and you
know basically about the beginning of
crack cocaine in the inner cities and
how that started
um
i think that is just such a brilliant
show and i
having come up working with you know
incarcerated youth during that time we
were really big in working with you know
a lot of the juvenile inmates and in the
prison system during those 80s and 90s
and
i was very involved with a lot of the
kids lives that were going through you
know slinging dope and making crack and
selling it and living in gangs and
protecting their turf
and you know here i am 25 30 years later
as you know 50 year old guy watching
this show
it's like one of my favorite shows on tv
and that's something that i saw close up
that wasn't you know living the life but
i was close to it and you know
integrated with people that were
i just think you know you talk about a
show that
you know you i think you learned so much
about the mindset of
you know it's a lot of people that it's
easy to
look down on people that live a certain
way and do a certain thing to make money
but you also have to look at the
circumstances and what their
surroundings are and either you're
selling or you're living on the streets
broke or you're selling you're gonna die
because there's a lot of people that got
pulled into it that you had to choose an
allegiance so a lot of the people that
got involved in that they didn't really
have a choice and a lot of people you
know it's it's good to remind people
where things come from i mean i think
there's some some interesting roads they
go down with the cia
funding some of that to kind of do their
own thing and that's that's all you know
if you're into that that's cool i mean i
don't take one side or another on that
but i i love the show because i care
about the characters you know we we meet
franklin and he's
this young
kid who lives in the hood who gets
brought into this underworld and he
becomes a kingpin of moving narcotics
into the not only the inner city but our
our world
and you know stories like that fascinate
me and i think a lot of people get that
from shows like narcos and
other shows i haven't seen that one but
you know i sometimes there's message you
know there's
interesting interesting things that come
from those about relationships and
loyalty
and you know sometimes i can get
inspired by a show like that that has
nothing to do with what i'm dealing with
on a day-to-day basis but it reminds me
of the importance of loyalty when i
think of our film crew or i think about
the people that we work with or our
friends or family
um you know so it's nice when those
little
these little things happen when you
watch a show that you don't expect from